civil war
somebody requested i say that right away
i had to do it
donald trump's home mar-a-lago has been
raided by the fbi this is according to a
statement from the president himself i
am seeing reporters on twitter say
something similar i have another source
who who messaged me saying another
journalist they have confirmed it
seems to be completely legit the hill is
reporting definitively that donald
trump's home has been raided by the fbi
it's unclear exactly why but boy do we
have to talk about this one cause this
is uh it's one of those moments when you
question how long until dark days you
get really really dark you know
i don't want to say too much but there
are times in history when we talk about
when people realized things were getting
too dangerous in their own country i
think the former president having his
home raided by the fbi
when he's already passively announced
he's going to be running for president
basically and we know that this is an
attempt to stop him from running dark
days indeed so
we'll be talking about that i'm just
going to jump straight into the promo
spot before we get started my friends
head over to surfinginternetsafe.com
to get virtual shield a virtual private
network service to help keep your data
safe while you browse the web there are
prying eyes government hackers just
regular all hackers want to steal your
data major corporations tracking
everything you do a vpn from virtual
shield gives you a basic layer of
security so again go to
surfinginternetsafe.com they say they're
vpn service it's compatible with all
devices it allows you to browse the web
safely securely and anonymously using
their global network of private ips it
allows you to browse the web so that big
name ip internet service providers and
other third parties will not be able to
monitor your internet activity
when you're using their vpn your traffic
is routed through their secure and
encrypted servers that means any
restrictions censorship and blocks are
bypassed it's completely free for 30
days works on mac windows iphone ipad
android and chrome does all the work for
you all you got to do is download it
press go you're good to go
they have personal family and business
plans available the family plan includes
15 devices business plan as many as you
want and it will actually encrypt your
wi-fi connection as well blocking
hackers and everyone else from accessing
any of your data shout out to virtual
shield they're our first sponsor they've
been here the entire time go to go to
surfing surfinginternetsafe.com and pick
up a vpn from them if you really if you
want to have some basic layer of
security and don't forget head over to
timcast.com become a member we're going
to have that uncensored members only
show coming up about 11 p.m and we've
got new episodes of tales from the
inverted world
i think s castle is going live with the
first promo introductory episode
tomorrow so we're really excited for
that and then we've got big news two
documentaries are moving forward in the
works and i believe the uh gun control
dock may actually be done in only a few
months because it is it is happening so
we're really excited for that it's
called what is an assault weapon
so that's really really cool so smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
joining us tonight it is an honor and a
privilege to have larry elder
tim thank you so much for having me i
appreciate it would you like to
introduce yourself to anyone who might
not be familiar with your work uh ran
for governor of california last year got
three and a half million votes uh got
more votes and virtually all the other
45 replacement rivals combined i've had
a talk show for about 30 years with
salem now i'm with epic times tv had a
syndicated column for about
since april of 1998. i missed one week
i was taking off for christmas you're
allowed to take two weeks off i took one
week off one year outside of that i've
written a weekly column every single
week since 1998 april except for when i
ran for governor i've had about a half a
dozen books two of which were new york
times best sellers one was called the 10
things you can't say in america which
came out in 2000
and my last book is about my father and
me we didn't talk for almost 10 years
because i had an issue with him
we sat down for what i thought would be
a five or ten minute conversation tim
ended up being an eight-hour
conversation after which i realized what
an amazing guy he was and i cried and
apologized we were very good friends
from that point on the next 35 years wow
well we are we're lucky to have we have
a star on the hollywood walk of fame
just so you know
i didn't know that corner corner
hollywood and vine southeast corner
really you want to touch me wow yeah
so now so now you can stand at the
corner and hear people in 25 languages
say who the hell is larry elder so there
you go it's quite quite exciting well we
are lucky to have you man i'm really
excited for this should be fun we also
have jamie kilstein i gotta stop giving
my introduction after the guest i'm like
well i'm playing the dayton funny bone
august 19th and 20th one of me and my
dad still don't really get along um hey
everybody i'm jamie colstein i am uh one
of the cast members and writers of cass
castle which you guys can see very soon
along with so much other good stuff at
timcast.com i am doing stand-up comedy
in dayton uh at the funny bone the 19th
and 20th zany's in nashville september
8th uh in the comedy catch in
chattanooga uh the ninth and tenth you
can follow me on twitter and also i just
want to say thank you guys um all the
people who have asked for me to come
back on the show on twitter and there
was uh there were fans i met irl fans uh
when i did stand up this weekend there
was literally a guy in the front row in
the middle of a comedy show there was a
little pause and he just goes thank you
for your nuance conversation on irl i
was like all right bud cool so yeah so
thank you guys
hey everybody ian crossland from
iancrossland.net happy to be here larry
you said you also have an upcoming movie
i do uncle tom thank you for it for i
forgot to mention that the sequel's
called uncle tom two uncle tom came out
on juneteenth in 2020. uh it costs about
half a million dollars to make the rule
of thumb is if you make three times your
your cost you have a hit movie uh it
made 10 times its cost wow had a higher
imdb rating than any of the ones that
were nominated that year for best uh
best documentary by the academy awards
uh higher rotten tomatoes rating and
couldn't get arrested by the academy
even though we had a consultant to try
and get it at least considered for uh
for consideration for an academy award
the sequel comes out on august 26th you
can pre-order it on uncle tom.com and
you can see uncle tom won for free also
on uncle tom absolutely excellent
excellent by the way yeah i'm looking
forward to talking about uncle tom too
later in the show so thank you thank you
thank you for reminding me and i
appreciate it you didn't have you didn't
have to do that but i love you man thank
you lydia's back i am back yes hold your
applause please my hand is in fact
broken if you can see it i'm going to
keep it to the chase but i think it's a
prop for sympathy that's true hold your
applause because you can't clap
exactly i cannot clap anyway let's get
into the news i'm excited for tonight
all right here's the first story ladies
and gentlemen this is massive
from timcast.com donald trump announces
mar-a-lago was raided by the fbi the doj
is currently investigating january 6 and
alleged efforts to overturn the 2022
election
i know
that timcast.com is officially newsguard
certified which is huge it's good news
right we'll talk about that later but i
also want to make sure we're just clear
the hill is reporting definitively the
fbi raids trump's mar-a-lago so while
many outlets are saying trump announces
it's happened there are there's at least
the hill saying it's definitive i have
another journalist who messaged me
confirming through multiples they say
confirming through multiple sources the
fbi has raided donald trump's home
they say or i should say we say over
timecast.com president donald trump
announced the federal bureau of
investigation has raided his private
real estate in florida mar-a-lago is
quote currently under siege raided and
occupied by a large group of fbi agents
the former president said in a statement
around 7 pm i mean this is this is
happening right when we're all excited
larry's here we're getting ready for the
show
he goes the fbi is raiding trump's house
and i was like what yeah it's like okay
well this is going to be crazy they say
the purpose of the search was not
immediately clear trump noted that
agents executing a search warrant even
broke into his safe the doj has
accelerated its investigation into the
january 6 attack on the capital and
further examined trump's actions to
overturn the 2020 election results uh
2020 election results iran in power
according to the hill
so
civil war what
i don't think so i think that this has
been planned for 100 years i'm not
talking about the raid on trump i'm
talking about technocracy and the you
know the military and well the military
part of it came in the 40s and 50s with
the opportunity after world war ii to
establish global dominance but like the
federal reserve they really want to
control the environment this is just
another stepping stone as far as i'm
concerned i think it's a very scary
development um
i i thought at first people who said if
donald trump gets indicted or if he gets
prosecuted for alleged insurrection uh
we we would be having some sort of
violence in the streets i don't i no
longer feel this hyperbole uh this is
very scary you know for the entirety of
trump's presidency hillary referred to
the election of 2016 as having been
stolen she called donald trump
illegitimate
to the point where 67 percent of
democrats according to a yougov poll
believe that the russians changed vote
tallies in 2016 to get donald trump
elected jay johnson the department of
homeland security secretary testified
under oath the russians tried but they
failed to change a single vote tally in
2016. yet a super majority of democrats
believe that they did 78 of democrats
believe the russian interference changed
the outcome of the election and j
johnson testified we don't know we'd
have to have a world where there was
interference and one where there wasn't
and compare the two so we can't do that
we just don't know but 78 of democrats
according to a gallup poll believe the
russian interference changed the outcome
of the election in other words a greater
percentage of democrats believe
2016 was stolen the republicans feel the
same thing about 2020. hillary joined a
lawsuit jill stein to overturn the
wisconsin election uh and uh and filed a
separate motion to have the recount done
by hand nobody calls her a purveyor of
the big lie her social media platforms
have not been shut down even though she
said as i said for four years donald
trump is an illegitimately elected
president it's a double standard that
slaps you in the face hillary skated
when she clearly violated the espionage
act she had a private server in her
basement she got and received secured
information uh classified information
lied about it and skated and the and the
law does not require any intent but
james comey did this big presentation at
the end of it he said but she lacked the
intent the statute does not require
intent she skated this is double
standard and it's outrageous and there
might very well be violence in the
streets now because there's a couple
ways i think we can we can look at it
depending on how you want to give the
benefit of the doubt to democrats donald
trump
was very passively looking into the
ukraine dealings of the biden family for
doing such he was accused of trying to
dig up dirt on his political rival just
before the upcoming election even though
joe biden had not announced nor even
hinted that he would be running for
president i mean this is like a year and
a half before he made his announcement
at all they impeached donald trump for
this right we do have evidence of
potential malfeasance i should say joe
biden did a quid pro quo with the
president of ukraine fire the prosecutor
or you're not getting the billion dollar
loan guarantee and they said well
it was in line with foreign policy
that's not the point the vice president
doesn't have the authority to make these
threats right as it happens his son was
on the board of barisma barisma's
founder was being investigated by that
prosecutor who ended up getting fired
because of biden now you could argue the
democrats
are looking at that and genuinely
believing that's what trump was doing
and this is what we've seen from them
they've repeatedly said you have to play
the game the republicans are playing if
they really believe that's what trump
did then this is a tit-for-tat or we can
operate on the assumption they're
hypocrites and liars they accused trump
falsely and then are now doing exactly
what they claimed he was doing and of
course uh hunter biden and joe biden are
getting a complete pass so far
joe biden has said repeatedly he knew
nothing at all about his other son's
business dealings they got the laptop
the laptop was dismissed as russian
disinformation by 51 so-called
intelligence operatives right before the
election 16 of biden voters believe that
had they known about this story they
would not have voted for biden uh and
and six percent right 16 16 16 of 16
of biden voters say had they known about
the hunter binding laptop story which
was suppressed by twitter suppressed by
facebook they would not have voted for
joe biden clearly the election then
would have been uh in favor of donald
trump uh and donald trump is referred to
as the big guy getting ten percent on
the laptop uh and they've and uh joe
biden a hundred buyers complaining that
his dad gets back
and the big guy gets ten percent and
they've done this again and if you watch
cnn you watch msnb what i call msnb
it's like this story doesn't even exist
but but on sunday even brian stelter of
cnn their uh their media guy even he
said this is not just a right wing story
it is something that's very serious and
could jeopardize biden's presidency i
want to read this statement from donald
trump here for you guys um his
announcement that this raid happened he
said
these are dark times for our nation as
my beautiful home mar-a-lago in palm
beach florida is currently under siege
raided and occupied by a large group of
fbi agents
nothing like this has ever happened to a
president of the united states before
after working and cooperating with the
relevant government agencies this
unannounced raid on my home was not
necessary or appropriate
it is prosecutorial misconduct the
weaponization of the justice system and
an attack by radical left democrats who
desperately don't want me to run for
president in 2024 especially based on
recent polls and who will likewise do
anything to stop republicans and
conservatives in the upcoming midterm
elections such an assault could only
take place in a in broken third world
countries sadly america has now become
one of those countries corrupt at a
level not seen before they even broke
into my safe
what is the difference between this and
watergate where operatives broke into
the democratic democrat national
committee here in reverse democrats
broke into the home of the 45th
president of the united states i mean
it's absolutely insane um
i think he missed an opportunity i'm not
the biggest fan of trump but i do think
he's the funniest president that what if
while they were raiding his place that's
when he just stood outside and announced
he was running for president defiantly
as they're like just moving safes out
he's like by the way i am running for
president i think that's the move i i
agree i actually said this a couple
weeks ago donald trump needs to announce
now before they try and pull some bs
like this
i also just want to say i don't think
they care
i don't think they care when he
announces whether he announces they
intended to do this it's just again
absolutely completely outrageous
steve bannon was just prosecuted for for
refusing a subpoena by the january 6
committee found found found guilty um
eric holder refused a subpoena by the
republican for information on fast and
furious they referred it to the court
and the federal judge who was appointed
by by obama throughout the uh throughout
the uh the lawsuit again just double
standard
yeah uh bannon was was charged with a
misdemeanor that was a misdemeanor what
he got found it was i think it was two
misdemeanors because of what what like
two requests or something yeah i just
wanted to also say uh
no violence in the streets you guys like
if we you know if we because we talk
about um
yeah that would be the worst possible
thing because it's gonna hurt of course
it would be yes a hundred percent and
it's also well because it's bad yeah
no but also like we talk about the both
side stuff right we talk about the bow
side stuff with this where it's well we
wouldn't have wanted obama to be raided
right so we don't want trump to be
raided it's the same thing with violence
in the street for everyone who
rightfully condemned violence in the
street when it was the left it's like we
don't want to do that however
i think people on the left as well when
something unconstitutional happens when
something shady happens when people need
to be held accountable still make your
voices heard the media should still
cover this responsibly but yeah we don't
need to uh no pitchforks yet well people
on the left uh because donald trump got
elected in november of 2016. there was
violence in four
over four days in 40 different cities a
number of people were arrested and when
donald trump was inaugurated in january
of 2017 200 people were arrested in
washington dc protesting the the
inaugural so the the idea that uh donald
trump supporters are more violent than
hillary supporters is just bs no well
and that's what's so frustrating is i
wish that
i wish that people and i say this every
time i'm on the show would have
principals and not parties and that
means if your side is doing the thing
that you criticize the other side for
not only should you call it out you
should be more upset
but that describes the right not every
single person on the right obviously but
today the right as the media describes
it is an amalgam of a bunch of different
political parties i mean libertarians
like it's funny when they they meme dave
smith because he makes a tweet about the
leftover reacting and they say here's
you overreacting and it's like january
6. it's like dave smith's a libertarian
right he rags on trump all the time dave
smith's also a comic hey what's up dave
right
so so the issue is like
whatever they describe the right as is
actually constantly pointing the finger
like hey that was bad you shouldn't do
that
whatever the left is is completely
oblivious or just outright does not care
and when you call them out they call it
what about ism i hear that all the time
it's called what about us
benny thompson is the chair of the
january 6 committee january 2005 after
george w bush gets re-elected he joins
88 other democrats
to overturn the election
claiming that there was a voter
manipulation in the debo voting machine
in ohio
and wasn't successful but he did not
want those electors to be seated nobody
called him uh threatening the integrity
of our democracy uh and democrats tried
to uh challenge electors in 2000 al gore
to this day believes the supreme court
uh put george w bush in the supreme in
the in the white house uh maxine waters
and others challenged 2004 along with
benny thompson
and more more states were challenged by
the democrats in 2016 in january than
donald trump challenged in 2020 in
january but but here's here's the issue
you've got a cult and everybody else and
i feel like
we can say that stuff all the time we
can make the memes and post the videos
maybe maybe it will
you know
wake a lot of people up but there is
still a massive base of people that
don't know don't care and even if you
tell them that they're going to say so
what i know they're driven by tribalism
and that's the problem right i think a
lot of people
on the left and in the on the right they
don't even realize the scope of the
bubble they're in they don't know about
the algorithms they don't know about
fact checking they don't know they just
see what the algorithm gives them and
it's usually people this is what
happened to me it's usually just people
who agree with them and then i hear
someone like larry talking about even
things about student debt and black
lives matter before the show that
literally i didn't know
now it's not
necessarily the average person's fault
you know this is our job right but it's
not the average person's fault for not
knowing it is their fault
for once you do find out something that
changes your narrative not going oh damn
okay maybe i need to change my mind or
look at that in a more open-minded way
can i just want to point out how
deluded deranged i think the democrats
are jamie raskin
sent me a text asking for money for a
political campaign
jamie raskin the guy who falsely who
smeared me on january 6 hearings
including a clip of me reading a fox
news article alongside other people
calling for a red wedding she texted me
saying
i need your help please donate now he
was he was by the way one of the 88
democrats that voted not to certify the
election in ohio in 2005 january like
unsubscribe
we're we're busted look i said i've been
saying civil war for some time not be
here's what people miss
there's single-layer issues and that
seems to be the only thing the left
understands they don't understand what
comes next but there are even many
people that that don't see beyond uh you
know the first second or third layer of
events back in 2018 when i'm watching
people fighting in the streets my point
when i said we're on track for a civil
war is that the culture war you're
seeing on the ground is going to reach
the highest level of government there's
no indication it won't be the case
now we're at the point where the fbi has
just raided the home of a former
president you can't get any higher than
that the doj of democrat administration
has raided the former republican
administration president's
house
they've arrested several of his
administration officials they've
shackled them it does not get any higher
than this
this shows the country to the highest
degree has bifurcated the good what
comes next
i don't know kansas believe in kansas
with what's going on the abortion voting
the uh the only reason i'm very hopeful
that there's not going to be a civil war
is because people on the right have guns
and most people on the left don't know
how to fight that's not the issue though
the issue is the doj has been weaponized
well that's not good so you hear people
on the right say oh the right's got guns
what is the left has well the socialists
have guns the socialist rifle club rifle
association exists and democrats are
weaponizing law enforcement in ways that
conservatives won't do jim let me give
you an idea how scary it gets i have a
friend that i've known for over 40 years
he was my closest friend he has a son
with special needs
and he's convinced that donald trump
quote mocked a disabled reporter there
was a poll in 2016 before the election
the number one reason likely voters gave
for not wanting to vote for donald trump
is because he allegedly mocked a
disabled reporter
the story was because donald trump said
there were people who were cheering the
fall of the twin towers
and to be sure there was a reporter who
wrote a story about that when the people
asked the reporter about the story he
backed away from it yeah and donald
trump mocked him backing away from it
began shaking like this i don't remember
i don't know so more like mocking him in
like a year right back there's a website
called catholics for trump
uh and there are several videos where
donald trump has used that gesture to
mock himself to mock an able-bodied
person and furthermore the reporter in
question his name is serge kovaleski
doesn't go like this right he has an
atrophy he has a some sort of uh disease
he has an atrophied arm but he doesn't
shake like this he speaks very calmly
and very evenly so he wasn't even doing
an impression of him
and i sent my friend a three-page letter
jamie with with a link to catholics for
trump to show him that he's wrong
and my friend by the way had a perfect
score in his s.a.t yeah close to a
perfect score on his lsat he's brilliant
and it didn't matter and i had an
epiphany i found out that people who
hate donald trump did not want to unhate
him had nothing to do with intelligence
it was all emotion and this guy was
invested in disliking donald trump
invested in this story it is not true so
i have a question you are and we ended
our friendship he ended it so what i was
going to say what i crazy what i respect
you for that interaction is you reached
out right and you refused the three-page
letter so i guess my question is i've
known you for a half an hour yeah or
however long
you know you seem like a
you've been very kind and intelligent
and i've learned things my question is
then how does someone and this is like
an honest question is
how would you if we're trying to avoid
civil war which seems like i don't know
a priority
um how does the right
how do you especially as like a public
figure
kind of try to not turn into
that same tribalized left how can you
or is it even your responsibility try to
get your fans to reach out but he's not
i mean quite literally if his whole
point is that he reads the facts to
figure out what's true right and someone
else doesn't you don't need to avoid
doing it you're just not doing it no but
what i'm saying is like
do people like us and i'm even counting
myself being on this show do we sort of
need to go above and beyond to instead
of just
attacking attacking attacking try to get
the other side to see the facts in a
compassionate way like you attempted
with your friend and then it's on your
friend that he didn't respond the
problem is one side and i'm generalizing
obviously one side the left believes the
right is not just wrong they're bad
people if not evil we believe or at
least i believe people on the left are
ill-informed uh and are need to be
better educated but i don't con i don't
dismiss them as evil bad people i have a
recent friend left is all get out name
is jackie
jackie jackie hates donald trump and
believes donald trump engaged in an
interaction a coup so i sent her an
article written by uh uh
alan dershowitz who is a left-wing
professor voted twice for obama but been
very fair very even on this issue and he
talked about the the 9 11 commission
committee how unfair it was how
one-sided it was that donald trump in
his speech said i want you to
patriotically and peacefully go over and
make your voices heard on and on very
very well argued i sent it to her text
it to her yeah
she texts back right away and says uh
this is garbage i wrote back and i said
you could not have possibly read it
in that time that you text back to me so
she refused to even read the information
what do you want me to do i wouldn't
open a window and just start yelling i
mean liberals are very fast readers this
is where i got i want to push back i
think this is a mistake that the right
often makes the saying is the right
thinks the left is ill-informed the left
thinks the right is evil in fact i think
the left is the example of the banality
of evil and it doesn't matter if it's
left or right any kind of historical
context
let's just call it blue and red or a and
b
whatever it is when you've got
libertarians
post liberal disaffected liberal
conservative republican whatever on one
side disparate ideologies people
disagree having a conversation and then
you have people who are driven by
emotion won't even bother to read the
facts you're dealing with a cult you are
dealing with the banality of evil they
are engaging in evil actions to evil
ends
for no specific reason they don't need
to have intent if a person
is you know look
if a person grabs a weapon and thinks
they're a good guy and like actually
i'll tell you a story right now there's
a viral story
where a guy murdered his neighbors
because he said they were using
telepathy to mind control him
yeah he's crazy he is he is a he
committed an evil act but his intent was
skewed by nonsense that doesn't change
the fact that what he did was evil so
i'm not going to call them ill-informed
i'm going to say they're engaged and not
right engaged and not right evil okay
well i do want to that's fair enough my
mother was a lifelong democrat my
brother my best friend was a lifelong
democrat i never considered them to be
evil i considered them to be
ill-informed and i worked on them and i
got them to vote for george w bush twice
my mother voted for ronald reagan they
wouldn't change the party because that
was a motion but i was able to reason
with them so i don't dismiss all of them
but you're quite right you take up
somebody like jeff zucker the former
head of cnn he's on tape project veritas
has people on tape uh at cnn uh
producers saying that in our nine
o'clock meeting every morning with jeff
zucker jeff ducker hates donald trump
has a vendetta against donald trump and
he wants us to do anti-trump stories to
the inclusion of other news that's evil
that's villain that's villainy well and
to your point about your family i feel
like my job here today is to stop a
civil war um instead of promote my gigs
um to your point i'm really glad you
brought up your family because what i
was gonna say and i'm not disagreeing
with you guys a ton but i want to say
that
twitter liberals
uh
antifa liberals
media liberals are far different
than
and same with conservatives than the
people i meet at jiu jitsu who we're all
hanging out we don't care about
political parties maybe people on the
left are like yeah i'm liberal because
like i don't care if gay people marry
and i'm against the war and that's kind
of all they know they're not on twitter
they're not trying to stir stuff up they
barely know about january 6th nor does
that care about it i had a meeting with
a friend in new york and when i tried
explaining to him that democrats tried
to legalize abortion up to the point of
birth he said that's impossible that
can't be true and i said if you are
actively speaking out this person with a
high profile platform in defense of
their bill without having read it
because you can't believe that i would
be right at all even though you didn't
read it that's the banality of evil when
people engage in evil actions and it's
become a normal process
what i don't understand though man is
like i'm an artist which means legally i
have to hate myself so i cannot be a
special case i cannot be the only person
that went in a room with you guys here's
something i don't know and go oh damn i
never thought of it that way i said i
feel like there are other people out
there like
during the debates bernie sanders was
specifically asked
do you believe that there's a point
beyond which an abortion is murder i
don't know and he basically said no
and when i was running for governor the
texas so-called fetal heartbeat bill got
passed and i was asked over and over
again about abortion because i'm
pro-life and i said when you just ask my
opponent gavin newsom just one time at
one point does he feel that pregnancy
has gone so far that it would be then
become become murder and they never ask
him and his position is up to including
the moment before before birth although
larry i can say if we
disagree on everything else the rest of
the show we can agree and become friends
on the fact that i too do not like gavin
newsom
he's got great hair though
he's so happy he looks like american
psycho you know regarding the banality
it's the basements in the body it's come
up a few times about accusing people of
being the banality of evil tim you have
actually called me the banality of evil
multiple times but i think that like
never stuck we're supporting
slavery in china that's getting us this
cheap technology like my my cell phone
was only 600 bucks instead of 1150
because it was was made by chinese
slaves we have factory farming like
that's not evil that's evil to do that
to animals and but we live that that's
part of our existence we are the
banality of evil as americans we are
fascists and that's just part of the
game right now i just i disagree so my
point on the banality of evil is an
individual who's taking direct action
that is evil uh this is interesting
point if you if you've ever watched the
show the good place yeah it's one of my
favorite things they make the point that
life has become so complicated it's
impossible to get into the good place
basically heaven because no matter what
you do you're doing something bad you
you buy some flowers for a friend to
cheer them up well those flowers have
pesticides which is killing bees which
came from slave labor
i can understand the complexities of of
human life on the planet and like you
mentioned sweatshop labor and all those
things
but there could be people who are
actively opposed to that speaking out
against it and trying to stop it the
difference is when you cheer on and vote
for intentionally fbi
rating that being weaponized to go after
people and destroy
that's very different it concerns me
because well at least i was taught like
that's not good you don't want to
support the evil that you're trying you
don't want to use evil to destroy evil
it doesn't work like that you become the
evil you're trying to end
um but i don't know if everybody was
raised like that and if they weren't
then i can't
maybe the banana but
they're banal is that the right word it
is now but i'm talking about two
different things
we're talking about two different things
though
i agree with you there is an issue that
we all kind of just churn along not
realizing that uh the computers we have
are made by people who are you know
foxconn labs when they're committing
mass suicide and things like that those
are all really bad and for a lot of
people like i immediately stopped using
iphones when i found out about that
granted a lot of components they'll come
from those factories but i was like i
didn't know i didn't know and when i
learned i said i have to change that i
can't get mad at you for the green
bubbles anymore but when it comes to
what's happening with what you know
larry's talking about trying to let them
know they say i don't care that's the
difference yeah
and what also was scary is the
unwillingness to look at the the result
of your actions even if your actions
were uh the intent was was a with a
valid intent or a a kind intent uh the
800 pound elephant in the room in this
country is the large number of kids who
enter the world without a father married
to the mother in 1965 25 of black kids
entered the world without a father
married to the mother and forget about
elder brock obama once said
a kid raised without a dad is five times
more likely to commit
to be poor and commit crime nine times
more likely to drop out of school and 20
times more likely to end up in prison
now it's 70 of black kids entering the
world without a father married to the
mother it's because the welfare state
has incentivized women to marry the
government and incentivize men to
abandon their financial and more
responsibility 40 of all kids in america
are born without a father in the house
25 of white kids half of all hispanic
kids and we are doing nothing about it
we're not even talking about even
republicans don't talk about it and when
you don't have a father in the house
it's not just an act a financial problem
which is which is huge it's you don't
see two adults interact civilly resolve
problems you don't see somebody get up
and go to work in the morning when he
doesn't want feel like going all the
values that it takes in order to be a
responsible citizen you don't have
that's why we have so much crime and
such dropouts right now and a lot of
people who are functionally illiterate
eight
eighty-five percent of eighth grade
black kids in america can either read
nor write at proficiency levels that
means eighty-five percent of eighth
graders black eighth graders are
functionally illiterate when you are
functionally illiterate you are easily
misled by emotion and it's a huge
problem and both both parties in my
opinion completely ignore that issue
yeah i think well i think it aids
certain political parties because the
kids end up looking to the government
they look for a strong one they look for
a father and a boogie man and they and
they look for something that made them a
victim and that's why so many black
people are misled and believing that
america systemically racist it is not i
was i was talking to uh i was i was
talking to some local school
professionals
and one of the things that i was talking
about with some people there was
people don't know what to do with their
lives people want to work hard but let's
say this let's say right now you
lost your job and you're like you know
what i really love doing i really love
making birdhouses
how do i start a company that makes
birdhouses i don't know step one the
funny thing is we look at video games
like world of warcraft so popular it's
gamified this this dopamine release
where you accomplish goals but it's fake
the difference i was talking about why
is it that people will sit there playing
a video game where they get the the
forest leather boots of agility but they
won't just go and actually level
themselves up right the thing is no
force boots that's why no it's because
in the real world there is no quest
giver who says if you do ten push-ups
you will then see plus one strength
they there's there's there's no
leadership and it's in line with what
you're saying about fathers when you
have someone who says here is your quest
and they accomplish their quest they get
a dopamine hit it feels good in a video
game they tell you what to do you do it
it works you've accomplished your goal
yeah this is what we were missing from
in real life we're starting to lose in
real life as you were mentioning with
with that and the irony the the
information to build a birdhouse and to
start a business has never been more
accessible all you do is go online never
has information been more easily
obtained and cheaply obtained than it is
right now but you don't have somebody to
give you guidance you'll have somebody
to tell you you need to defer
gratification work hard there's a
connection between that and and having a
good result and this is why i think the
the one of the reasons the democrats are
so hell-bent on stopping school choice
because you keep people ignorant what
happens they graduate from college doing
the wrong things and then think
i don't understand what i'm supposed to
do if what i did didn't work the system
must not work meanwhile people with
proper guidance succeed they find that
success and they say
you can make it you can make it happen
so what i want to see happen is people
get good guidance and leadership so they
know those first steps absolutely but
that's not what we're getting from the
school system that's not what we're
getting from welfare programs what we're
getting from david goggins right people
like goggins and rogan and you tim
people like everything i'm following
your work larry you know but uh you
people like larry elder like every time
i struggle every time i'm depressed i
don't go to a therapist i'm like typing
david doggett
i literally looked up jocko breakup
advice after my last breakup um jordan
peterson
as i said i've been on radio for 30
years and in 30 years i have not been
able to get jesse jackson on my radio
show maxine waters uh al sharpton uh
louis farrakhan even though i've reached
out to them hundreds of times
the one so-called black leader terminal
piglet like who came on my show is a guy
named kawasa infume he's a congressman
from maryland
at the time he was a president of the
naacp he was a congressman both before
and after becoming president of the
naacp and my first question was mr
imphume as between the presence of white
racism or the absence of black fathers
which poses the bigger problems of the
black community without missing a beat
ian he said the absence of black fathers
again far and away the biggest problem
and barack obama's first book was all
about the angst over not having a dad in
this house a dream from my father al
sharpton
had a nice middle class life until his
father ran away with another woman into
the hood he went uh louis farrakhan's
mother was estranged from
her husband had a boyfriend took back up
with louis farrakhan
and she tried to abort him with a coat
hanger jesse jackson's mother was a
teenage mom who lived next next door to
a married man who impregnated her and
jackson grew up in south carolina when
growing up without a dad was rare and he
was teased jesse ain't got no daddy just
ain't got no daddy the reason i'm
mentioning this is these are arguably
the four most prominent so-called black
leaders all of whom either have no
relationship with their dads or a poor
relationship with one and they never
talk about it obama every now and then
says something but by and large they
never talk about it they talk about
racism racism racism when it's never
been less significant in america you
mentioned early in the show you're dead
and that you had you know a 10-year
period maybe falling out right but prior
to that how was it for you growing up
with your dad well my father uh was was
grouchy and angry and he spanked us a
lot my two brothers with with belts i
thought it was excessive and i intently
disliked the man and fortunately when
i'm a little kid he 10 years old he
starts a little cafe and i have to work
for the slb and he still yells it man
now i'm 15 years old tim and i said to
myself next time he yells it man we're
talking about a diner where everybody
can hear everything it's not like it's
privately in the back he yells and
screams at me and you're looking at
customers watching the whole thing i
said i'm going to walk out next time
this slb yells at me and it took me
three or four times to hit work up the
courage to do it but i did when i was 15
years old
my dad came home he paid me 10 dollars a
day plus tips he bought the ten dollars
and lay on the bed he threw it at me and
he said why did you leave and for the
first time i spoke back to my dad and i
said dad i got sick and tired of the way
you spoke to me i'm not putting up with
it anymore he walked out of my bedroom
tim and for the next 10 years we didn't
speak to each other at all wow at all i
go to college i go to law school i come
home to visit my mom of course college
was in new england law school's in the
midwest i'd come back to l.a to visit my
mom but i'd make sure my dad wasn't
around when i when i was in the room you
were 15
i was 15 when this happened
uh but then i graduated from high school
my dad worked long hours for the next
two years i just made sure we weren't in
the same room then then i go to new
england for for college midwest for law
school end up working in cleveland and i
would visit my mom all these years of
course but i would just make sure my dad
and i were not in the same room we said
nothing each other for 10 years now
just just real quickly um
now i'm 25 years old i passed the
california bar the ohio bar i should be
living large i'm 25 years old making the
equivalent of 150 k
and i can't sleep
and i know it has to do with my dad so i
told my secretary call my uh call my
client tell them i'm going to be away
for three days i'm flying to l.a i'll be
back
and so i didn't tell my parents i was
coming because i didn't want my dad to
prepare so i go to get to lax took a cab
to the cafe cafe closed at 2 30. i got
there at 1 30
and my dad was shocked to see me i had
two big bags with me and he said i put
your bags in the back i said no dad i
would be here for five or ten minutes i
want to tell you something
so he said wait till we close so i sat
there for an hour and i said
all right don't tee off on the sob just
give him the highlights five ten minute
conversation he'll call you an
ungrateful grateful son you'll call him
a cruel father and maybe you'll be able
to sleep when you get back to cleveland
so my dad sat down and i teed off for
him for a half hour you know how i can
go we just now met but you know how you
know
so i spoke for a half hour non-stop
every spanking every whipping the time
when my cousin elaine came to cleveland
from cleveland to visit me and he with
me in front of her how humiliating that
was i told him everything and my dad
just took it every now and then he'd
lean over and pour coffee and replenish
his coffee but he just took it
and when i was done i was spent i
couldn't think of anything else and my
dad looked up and said is that it
you just be you didn't speak to me for
10 years because of that now i should
tell you i knew nothing about my
father's life other than i knew he was
an only child because we never got any
christmas presents and i met his mom one
time outside of that i knew nothing
about his life i didn't care i didn't
like him
he said let me tell you about
my father
you know your last name elder i said yes
he said that's not my father's last name
i said what
what's your father's last name he said i
have no idea i never met him you never
met your father who's elder elder was
some guy who was in my life the longest
four years my mother couldn't either
read nor write she had a series of
boyfriends each one more irresponsible
than the one before elder was an
alcoholic was physically abusive to me
and when i tried to stop him from
beating my mother he would beat me
and i came home at 13 years old he said
and i started fighting with my mom's
then boyfriend by that time elder was
long gone
and my mother sided with the boyfriend
and threw me out of the house 13 years
old never to return athens georgia jim
crow south at the beginning of the great
depression i said well dad
what did you do and for the next eight
hours the man told me about his life two
stools as close as you and i are
and
for the first time i found my i saw my
father cry when he talked about the way
elder treated him
for eight hours my dad walked me through
his life i said what did you do when you
left the house i went down the road i
picked up trash i did this
i became a pullman porter they were the
private largest private employers of
blacks in those days my dad came out to
california on a run and he was able to
walk through the front door of a
restaurant and get served and he was
shocked and he said maybe i'll make a
middle note to relocate to california
pearl harbor my dad joins the marines i
said dad why the marines anybody who's
listening to us who's in the marines
knows what i'm going to say two reasons
number one the goal of the action is
number two i love the uniforms my dad
was stationed on guam
where he became a staff sergeant in
charge of cooking for the colored
colored soldiers gets out come back to
chattanooga where you're appearing thank
you um and once i worked that in uh
where he met where he met married my mom
to get him a job as a short order cook
that's what he did in the military and
they said i'm sorry we don't hire
[ __ ] he went to restaurant after
restaurant i'm sorry we don't hire
[ __ ] because an unemployment office
goes through the door lady says you went
through the wrong door i said colored
only my dad goes through that door to
the very same lady who sent him out my
dad told my mom this is bs i'm going to
la where i was before the war i'm going
to get a job as a cook i'll send for you
comes out to la walks around for a day
and a half and he said sorry you don't
have any references
my dad said i need references to make
ham and eggs
and
but they treated him the same way as
they did in in chattanooga
a little more polite yeah
close to the unemployment office just
one door this time lady didn't have
anything my dad said what time do you
close she says diane what time do you uh
what time do you open she said what time
do you close five my dad said i'll be
sitting in that chair until you find me
something sat there for a whole day
nothing came back the next day she calls
him up i've got something i don't know
whether or not you're going to want it
my dad of course i'm going to want it
i'm starting a family what is it she's a
job cleaning toilet and nabisco brand
bread my dad did that for 10 years took
a second full-time job cleaning toilets
at another bread company he had a hookup
cook for a family on the weekend to make
additional money went to night school
three nights a week to get his ged so he
could have a stay-at-home wife
the man never slept which is why he was
so grouchy and my dad then said you know
and the other the other time i was
married
you were married before mom oh
i thought you're gonna say six months
three months
seven years what happened she cheated on
me she couldn't have any kids and then
the other time i was married
you were married twice before a mom
i was 18 years old i married a girl 18
her parents found out i was an eighth
grade dropout march her down to the
courthouse annulled the marriage so you
were married three times
why would you get married after that
happened to you he looked at me like i
had eight heads he said because larry i
wanted you
so eight hours my dad gets bigger and
bigger and bigger tim elder gets smaller
and smaller and smaller now i'm crying
and i said dad please forgive me for
judging you so harshly my dad said don't
worry about it just follow the advice
i've always given you and your brothers
like it's cited in my sleep hard work
wins you get out of life what you put
into it larry you cannot control the
outcome but you are 100 in control of
the effort and before you moan and groan
by what somebody did to you or said to
you go the nearest mirror look at it and
ask yourself what could i have done to
change the outcome and finally he said
no matter how good you are how hard you
work bad things are going to happen to
you how you address those bad things
will tell your mother and me if we
raised a man from that point on next 35
years my dad and i were the best of
friends i wrote a book about this called
dear father dear son two lives eight
hours
um about the conversation the reason is
titled that
and i flew back to cleveland my dad
wrote me a letter he never wrote me a
letter in his life
and it started out dear son he never
called me dear son never call me son i
wrote back and i called him father i
never called him father and my dad and i
became the best of friends from that
point on but if anybody anybody had a
right to hate america to believe america
was systemically racist it's my dad and
he never believed that my dad was a
republican and my dad always said this
about the democratic party and then i'll
then i'll shut up
democrats want to give you something for
nothing when you try and get something
for nothing you almost always end up
getting nothing for something
larry will you be my dad
let me ask you then uh based on what
your dad was saying
you mentioned um jim crow's self
your father they wouldn't give him work
outright slurring adam
why don't you first i guess the question
is what do you think systemic racism is
and then why would you say there isn't
any well systemic racism means top-down
stuff uh the way it used to be during
jim crow
uh i'd ask you to give me the example of
of a corporation fortune 500 corporation
an institution uh college media uh
military where there's top down racism
you can't come up with it the the
media is really relentlessly left-wing
academia same thing the military
is quite diverse
give me give me the name name the
corporation whenever whenever there's a
corporation where somebody says
something arguably racist like texaco
did a few years ago ceo on tape
referring to the employees as i don't
think he said inward but he said
something disparaging goes on tv
apologizes texaco loses
hundreds of millions of dollars
in equity uh and then they end up having
a program to advance the
the careers of the black employees of
texaco papa john remember that he was on
a call one time he said something
he was quoting somebody else and said
the n word lost his own company uh there
john there's a guy named john o'sullivan
he used to be the editor of the national
review he said white racism exists but
its social power is weak the social
power against it overwhelming there's no
upside today in any corporation
blatantly openly even subtly being
racist so let me let me uh get your
thoughts on this i was uh i was down
covering the ferguson riots back when
the michael brown stuff happened and i
did a documentary on what people they
refer to as systemic racism
what they what how it was explained to
us is st louis is actually a very small
city
outside of st louis and st louis county
actually it's like 90 some odd cities
right these cities were formed uh when
uh are you familiar with pruitt i go
it was one of the first if not the first
like
community housing project housing and it
was in st louis and one once it fell
into disrepair you started to get crime
in the area things started to get bad
and white people in st louis started to
flee the city and then form new new
surrounding suburbs i bet you
middle-class blacks also fled the city
it's possible but so what happens today
is
you have areas that are
you end up uh seeing racially
fractured communities one area is all
white they had racial covenants which
were eventually made illegal but then
you have you know a white grandfather
gives it to his son who gives it to his
you know son or whatever you have areas
that are predominantly white black or
otherwise what ends up happening is
you have impoverished black people as a
result of a lot of these policies
because of the way the cities are set up
they should move
well and nothing stopping them from
moving move we interviewed people and
asked them about it and they said move i
i lived in cleveland for a number of
years and i remember
when i first got there in 1977 there was
a newscast of all these white people
living in akron uh where there was 25
unemployment complaining about the steel
mills uh going going away rust belt and
i was looking at the television i said
move
move move but for what's stopping you
from moving get out of jail
so in jail so
i want to get your thoughts on on with
the accusation i'm on their claims
what ends up happening is something they
call going on tour
where if you have a busted tail light
and you drive from your town four miles
to your job you go through four or five
cities you get pulled over in each one
you get a ticket in each one and then
you go on tour through their jails where
one twenty dollar infraction you can't
pay for turns into four weekends in jail
where they keep trading you to next
police the police stations
so
this is this is what they refer to as
remnants of racial covenants which
created multiple jurisdictions which
have a negative impact on people today
we did ask people why don't you move the
area well people who have negative bank
accounts i mean theoretically could just
start walking but i think for a lot of
people that they don't know or it's just
not reasonable i suppose i'm not saying
that is systemic racism it's what they
claim is systemic racism and it's how i
of course followed ferguson greatly and
the obama white house comes in and they
accuse the ferguson pd of being
systemically racist for the reasons that
you mentioned it turns out that ferguson
is 67 black but 85 percent of the
traffic stops were of black people 18
point gap ergo systemic racism
apply that same logic to new york new
york at 25 black but almost 55 percent
of the traffic stops are for black
people that's a 30 point gap even bigger
than ferguson yet nypd offices street
officers majority of them are people of
color turns out that obama did a study
called race and traffic stop came out in
2013 by the national institutes of
justice which is a research arm of the
doj and you name the traffic offense a
black motorist was more likely to
violate it whether it was speeding
driving without a uh without a with an
expired tag driving without the proper
headlight uh driving without a seat belt
driving without a child safety seat in
the back when you have a kid you name
the offense black motors were more
likely to commit the offense stop
committing crimes if your if your help
if your tail light is busted fix it
don't expect people to give you some
slack just because you're black fix it
take responsibility the so the response
we got was that if you have to choose
between paying for gas or registering
your plate or whatever people are going
to choose probably to pay for the guests
to move the car knowing that they're
going to get you know they run the risk
the issue is the structure of the
jurisdictions turning one infraction
into four which then results in
you get a ticket you can't pay it's 50
bucks you say well i couldn't pay for
the 20 registration i can't pay for the
50 fine so the police come and they say
you're going to spend a weekend in jail
then but the moment you get out of jail
the next department is waiting right
outside saying you're coming to us next
so what they refer to as institutional
racism is not that the individual
officers are being racist but that due
to the remnants of the past
there are negative consequences for
people who live in this jurisdiction
jurisdiction today and they don't know
what to do to stop it solve it or get
out
again i i would just say it's a real
simple solution don't commit crimes uh
in in baltimore where freddie gray died
freddie gray died in police custody
remember he was the one who was in the
van yeah there were six officers who
were prosecuted three of the officers
were black the state attorney who
brought the charges with black city
council was all democrat majority black
the mayor was black number one number
two running the police department black
the u.s attorney general at the time
loretta lynch is black as was the
president
now these are black people running the
entire system and still people are
talking about it being systemically
racist i'm reminded of that joke that
wanda sykes said how are you going to
complain about the man when you are the
man
and
i'd like to know what the officials are
in st louis who they are in all these
areas my suspicion is they're regular
people trying to do their jobs and
they're not bigots
i i just think this is difficult you can
still say the system's broken you can
still say that people should not be
dying in police custody you can still
say that cops need better training
but do them on a case-by-case basis
that's what i'm saying it should be case
by case and it always has to be all or
nothing when we're screaming at each
other on twitter but like a lot of times
it's not racism it's that cop didn't
train jiu jitsu and doesn't know how to
put on a proper choke holder doesn't
know when a person is completely out and
just needs to be trained there's a city
in in
california called rialto we all told 100
000 people racially it reflects the
demographics of california the same
percentage of hispanics blacks asians
his and whites
and the cops a few years ago were
ordered to wear body cams they didn't
want to at first
and they wore them after a year what
happened
police complaints fell 90 percent
and police use of force fell 50 not
because the police were engaging in any
kind of different uh activity they were
they behaved as they always were always
been trained civilians stopped lying on
them
and they started complying and as a
result the police didn't need to use the
force anymore they stopped filing
lawsuits
and because it is
illegal to file a false lawsuit against
a cop so it turns out the civilians were
the ones who were making a bunch of
false allegations as did michael brown
during ferguson uh michael brown's
friend uh who said hands up don't shoot
turned out to be a complete lie even
obama it was uh i think holder uh eric
holder is a uh
department of justice
at the time yeah and it turns out that
um
the michael brown's dna was on the
officer's gun he tried to get the gun
and his friend i think his name was
dorian johnson or something said that my
friend said hands up don't shoot and
turns out a complete and total lie they
lied the police are lied on all the time
and when they got busted uh because of
rialto they stopped doing it i just
wanted to circle back real quick to what
you were saying about
actually what tim was saying about this
kind of
when you feel like you're you're
underwater right i don't have money to
to get out of these situations i think a
lot of what we're talking about right
now
it's institutional problems right it's
the government welfare state we're we're
doing a lot of talking about them but
for people
listening to the show
right
before you
have a kid before you're ready or split
um on the mom before you end up in a
situation i mean man i've been in
situations where
you just feel like
you just feel like checking out is the
only answer where it's you know you're
broke and you finally get a thing and
then that falls through and then you
just keep digging digging digging
digging digging what's your
because man i was so touched by the
story you told about your dad
what's your personal advice so forget
the institutions it's real simple
listening uh they're probably the most
prominent think tank on the left is the
brooking institution
and one of the ones on the right is
called the american enterprise institute
they don't agree on anything but they
agree on what they call the millennial
success sequence
finish high school
ideally one where you can read write a
compute at grade level that's why i
support school choice but first of all
finish high school don't have a kid
until you're 25 years old until you're
20 years old get married before you have
the kid get a job keep that job any job
even a minimum wage job don't quit until
you get another job within six months
you'll get a raise and finally avoid the
criminal justice system
committing an act of crime is a
voluntary act you don't have to do it
you follow that formula you will not be
poor and you'll get to the middle class
you don't there's a very good chance
you're going to be poor so there's uh i
i uh i agree mostly i would just say
when it comes to at least where i grew
up they were ignorant of the laws no
excuse for breaking it so i as well as
many other people
have found ourselves unwittingly having
committed a crime not realizing it was
because those seemingly innocuous like
when you get a ticket when you're
driving in illinois you can keep driving
there's no no problem you got a ticket
it's like so you drive they take your id
you keep the ticket when you get pulled
over you show them the ticket they say
okay you pay it off they send you your
id back what i didn't know because they
don't tell you this in driver's ed or
anything is that if you get two moving
violations under the age of 21 they
suspend your license so sure enough i
got a class a misdemeanor which was a
threat of a year in jail and like a 2
500 fine it wasn't just something i
could avoid i didn't even know it was
happening so that took away my ability
to drive for like two years because not
only was my license suspended then i got
caught driving on a suspended license
which i didn't even know was suspended
and you couldn't blame systemic racism
well so he did
my point is simply though you know
i feel like the system is is it a simple
way to put it is it might be easy to say
avoid the law but for a lot of people
the system is just busted yeah one same
with these ways right i was just gonna
say same with um
sex education so much sex education is
not the best in this country and i feel
like especially
for if you're pro-life you should want
the best sex education possible so that
people don't even get into this a
situation where they would even want an
abortion so maybe a lot of it does start
with education when it comes to the law
when it comes to learning to trade when
it comes to sex education i think but
but tim it's hard to go to jail they
don't want you to go to jail especially
when you're young they have all sorts of
programs juvenile programs diversionary
programs it is hard to go to jail you've
got to commit a crime to go to jail
you've got to hurt somebody to go to
jail it's hard to go to jail they don't
want to put you there gavin newsom
released 8 000 convicted felons some of
whom were violent felons because of of
covet they don't want you there
the idea that somebody is hiding behind
a tree with a net looking to snare black
people is just a it's just a lie for
sure sure but you know and again i think
we're outside of racism at this point
just talking about you know i
passed the success i would agree for the
most part uh with you i think the issue
of crime is not even about jail it was
about i wasn't able to drive for for so
for for two years on it for this point
it's like that'll make it harder to get
a job i couldn't do anything i was like
so i was like okay i guess i'll go live
in the city where i don't need to drive
i had no choice you're still in america
absolutely still in america where where
people in cuba are breathing shark
infested waters to get here where people
from haiti are trying to get here
central america mexico they would love
to trade places with us as we sit here
and mine now [ __ ] and moan about
relatively minor things now i agree with
you on that my attitude on all this
stuff is when you tell people to move
like that's actually what i did so i had
i did that 200 bucks in my pocket and i
found a rideshare to california and i
was like i'll sleep on the beach i don't
care i'm not going to stay in a bad
situation and so my attitude actually is
very much in line with that so pick up
your cards and play them to the best of
your ability that is your duty that is
your moral obligation i thought it was
interesting that you talked about not
knowing the law about the the tail
wasn't tail lights or uh uh suspended
license getting right like it's systemic
ignorance maybe of the law but what it
makes me think of when i think of
systemic racism is that 200 years ago
all these black people from africa were
slaves and they were intentionally not
educated they were intentionally not
taught to read and write then they were
eventually let out or whatever slavery
ended they had kids they didn't know how
to read and write they didn't know how
to teach their kids the kids didn't know
how to read right then they had kids and
for the most part
education is passed down generation
through the family without that we have
a systemic ignorance problem but they
call it racism just because they happen
to have been from africa those slaves
they could have been
they could have been like italian you
know they just weren't at that time but
maybe there was a reason that their skin
color was dark i just don't think it's a
skin color issue
that's a good point i think the
implication today is
you know often what i talk to people
about is the policies of racism have
like been made illegal and and you
actually can make they're people who
make money suing whenever they perceive
it like right now you've got these
selected videos where a muppet person
won't hug a black kid but they don't
show you the videos where the muppet
people don't hug the white kids either
and things like that they're just very
bad muppets you guys or whatever you
call them i don't know if they're
muppets
it's rosita and it took place at sesame
place in philadelphia uh and there's
video showing rosita high-fiving white
kids ignoring blackheads and when
somebody made the video put it on on web
uh it went viral and a bunch of other
people who went to sesame place over the
years
found videos where this thing was
happening so maybe something is going on
there but my problem is this uh this 25
million dollar class action lawsuit been
filed jesse jackson writes a letter to
sesame place accuses him of engaging
systemic racism the family that filed a
lawsuit is from baltimore
philadelphia has had black mayors
the
police chief is a black female the
superintendent of school is a black
person
the family from baltimore files a
lawsuit as i mentioned there are 13
public high schools in baltimore where
zero percent of the kids can do math at
grade level zero percent 13 high schools
another half a dozen where one percent
can that's half of all the high schools
in baltimore where the kids in the inner
city are either zero proficient in math
only one percent uh are proficient jesse
jackson said nothing about that he said
nothing about the fact of philadelphia
where sesame place is is on track to
register the highest number of murders
in the city's history most of them are
black jackson says nothing about that
but he goes ballistic over some
four-year-old kid not being high-fived
by rosita it's ridiculous and whether or
not this kid responds to this in a
sensible way depends entirely upon the
parent to put it in perspective where's
jackson on these other things nowhere do
you think that leads to
more people taking
actual racism less seriously absolutely
it does because it trivializes the whole
the whole word racism well and that's
what i was wondering and that's been one
of the things that has
gotten me so just
over so much of the left it's that if
you start conflating
um a sexist joke with sexual assault if
you start conflating the muppet thing
with you know actual hate crimes then
you're getting all of these people that
are just gonna
suddenly they hear the word racism and
they go oh what like that stupid muppet
thing and you're
you're essentially
you're taking away any meaning from it
because
i don't think you're saying that racism
isn't real but the problem is if we're
talking about these fake stories then we
can't actually come up with solutions
about what to do with real racism and i
thought about our friend bill ottman who
did the minds convention that we all
performed at and he actually had because
you were talking about a lot of black
intellectuals not going on your show but
he had coleman hughes on a panel with
cornell west and it was awesome because
they were respectful to each other and
they were both looking for solutions and
i think it is so
cowardly
of democratic black intellectuals not to
go on your show because it shouldn't be
about we're just going to shout talking
points at each other if you care about
racism you want all voices from all
political sides to be like hey man
there's a problem what do we do to fix
it but let me just say
as you mentioned you've got murder
you've got homicide but what are these
lawyers going for
perceived slight set up at a wealthy
theme park or something maybe it's just
for the lawsuits well not wealthy we
were poor and couldn't afford disney
world
i did c-span yesterday yeah for two
hours and a guy calls up black guy and
he says you know i watch a lot of black
talk show hosts and i never see you on
any of them yeah i never see you on uh
on uh roland martin's show he said uh i
never see you on any of the other shows
and i said well i debated roland martin
before the election i killed him sure uh
he has a radio show he's never invited
me on it um charlemagne the god has a
very popular show yeah
reached out to him to have him come on
my radio show didn't hear back i was
going to be i was on a flight uh a few
months ago with a guy named a guy named
bill bellamy sat next to me he said you
know he's comedian yeah yeah yeah yeah
and we had a long conversation and he
said you know one of my friends is
showing me the guy why don't you go on
his show and i said can you set that up
he said yeah i can do that we exchanged
information i never heard back yeah now
we want to just show up knock on the
door say hey interview me right it
doesn't work that way
you got to be invited yeah tim invited
me on this show i didn't just show up
yeah that would have been awesome
hi tim
yeah
you got two hours yeah if you showed up
randomly knocked on the door we'd roll
out the red card
you'd be invited that would have been so
funny joy reid hasn't had me on the show
the view hasn't had me on invite me i'm
there yeah i mean i'm easy to find we
have gotten to a point where everything
is so tribalized that the idea of having
a
black conservative
people are just so used to
ice cream by talking points at you you
scream your talking points at me instead
of like hey man no if we all want the
best for these struggling communities
then you need to hear a diversity of
opinions absolutely there's a magazine
called ebony ebony for a time was the
most popular black magazine came out
once a month it still comes out it
doesn't have the same power it has right
now owned by a different family and
every year they had a feature jamie
called the 100 most influential black
americans
and every year excluded from that list
were clarence thomas
thomas soul
who was absolutely brilliant he's he was
once called by david mamet the
playwright america's greatest
contemporary philosopher not included in
ebony and walter williams the first and
only black person that i know of to be
the chairman of an economic department
of a non-historically black college well
they need it they don't even know who
these people are yeah i didn't know i
didn't know thomas
yeah and i knew clarence thomas is like
the pube guy like that that's all we're
told on the left you know what i mean
where even if you disagree with him it's
like well you have to have a black hole
how do you exclude somebody who's on the
supreme court yeah one of the most
influential black people in america i
agree how do you do that yeah but they
did it every single year and of course i
was never in it and a bunch of other
people who are uh younger uh black
conservatives were never in it yeah have
you uh
seen the you've seen the polling data
probably more so than i on uh black
voters as it pertains to the democrats
moving forward and it's looking really
bad i hear is that is that correct yeah
well it's down blacks are still the only
major demographic where where biden is
still above water and by the way since
you brought this up there's this
business about uh drop kicking biden
kamala harris in favor of somebody else
because their poll numbers are so bad
common harasses are worse than uh than
joe biden's never going to happen the
nominee in 2024 the democratic side will
be kamala harris really joe biden can't
make it they have no choice black people
are the most loyal part of the
democratic base and black women are more
loyal than black men and her approval
among black females probably in the mid
70s and if they perceive carmel harris
to be dropkicked for somebody else
especially a white man after for decades
they've indoctrinated black people into
believing when you criticize a black
person often the criticism is because of
sexism and racism they cannot do that
they painted themselves into a corner
the only way kamala harris leaves is if
she says i want to leave i'm not
competent i want somebody else to take
my place and she's not going to do that
because she ran for president but have
you heard the theories that she'll take
some prestigious offer or an ngo or
something or a big deal only only if she
says okay i want to leave voluntarily
but if she's perceived as being kicked
out they will black women will not they
will not vote republican they just won't
vote but so so even outside of that um
it's looking like the polling has gotten
so bad they say
if democrats lose i think uh they need
at least 80 percent of the black vote in
order to win right if the polling for
them
uh if the polling for republicans rises
above 20 or something like that like the
democrats lose out right and that's it's
looking like we're there that's right
because the democrats have lost the
white vote since 1964. they rely on
convincing black people that the issue
is social justice not crime not schools
uh not breakdown of the family but but
the fact that there's systemic racism
and democrats have convinced black
people that that's the number one
problem facing america but something
weird is happening the democratic party
got whiter in the past couple of years
and wealthier right it's like they're
abandoning that they've always been yeah
there's a book called who really cares
by a guy named arthur c brooks
he was he was a uh public policy
professor at syracuse he wasn't even
particularly conservative and he found
out nobody ever done extensive study on
whether or not liberals or conservatives
were more generous or less generous so
he did a study and he found out much to
his surprise that conservatives were far
more generous with their time and with
their money than liberals uh contrary to
what he thought and it's for two reasons
first of all conservatives are more
religious than uh than liberals
religious
liberals give just as much money as
religious conservatives do but they're
just fewer of them and secondly most
conservatives believe that welfare
should be done people-to-people church
to church organization organization not
government and they walk the walk and
talk the talk and so it's really
interesting how a lot of black people
perceive the republicans to be only
concerned about money when in fact
they're more generous with their time
and with their money than liberals are
what do you think is going to happen in
uh
in the midterms or in 2024 with uh with
particularly with the black folk but i'm
wondering if this precipitates just well
i think republicans are spiking the
football a little early on the midterms
uh because uh inflation's getting a
little bit better the gas prices are
getting a little bit better and they
were able to spend the job report even
though most of these jobs that were
created the last month were part-time
jobs and the media is still in bed with
joe biden they can't stand republicans
they fear deathly fear that donald trump
will wear his ugly head in 2024 and so
no matter what it is they spin it in
favor of joe biden i mean the guy
doesn't even know where he is
and the hunter biden story has been
suppressed still and they're not
connecting the dots it's not about
hunter biden's crack habit i don't care
about that i care about whether or not
joe biden is compromised and apparently
he is yeah what what i i've been saying
this man people uh they look at the
historical trends where uh the
president's party loses seats in their
first term they're looking at these the
the the misery index saying democrats
are going to get crushed and then there
are some polls that just came out
recently in aggregate showing that the
the race has tightened that republicans
so for for months we're talking about
how republicans were up three three
points in the generic ballot which is
apocalyptic for democrats now it's like
point one mm-hmm or even i think 538
hasn't inverted democrats have took the
lead against that's right still
historically that should signal
democrats losing but i'm telling people
if you look at that stuff and you think
that means you know
if if you're looking at all this stuff
and you think you've got in the bag you
don't people need to go out and act as
though no matter what the no matter what
the polls are you need to get three or
even ten of your friends to go out and
vote yeah we're treating biden right now
like a like a toxic boyfriend or
girlfriend where it's like i know i
should break up with her but i don't
want to get back on tinder like and it's
like
we have to we have to hold it well and
we don't know how the reversal of roe v
wade is going to play um right there
between now and then that seems to have
helped democrats it has yeah so if you
look at the real certainly help their
fundraising absolutely and if you look
at real clear politics you can see that
the gap just closed from democrats to
republicans in aggregate this is not one
single poll yeah and again i don't even
know if i'm a democrat anymore you guys
i've been calling myself a bleeding
heart centrist but i will say like four
liberals listening
you want to hold your party accountable
you want to have the best democratic
party that actually has values and
morals and isn't just a bunch of
corporate hacks you want the best
for your party you don't want to just
blindly support a president who's doing
a terrible job because that is bad for
the future of the party that's bad for
you but who are you talking to i don't
know man there's another person out
there like me somewhere listening you
just changed somebody's life yeah i hope
so i feel like for you you had to get
thrown to the wolves by the left before
you finally well that's why i'm trying
to help everybody listening it's like
guys don't rock bottom like me don't let
your life be destroyed before you're
like maybe i should have a republican
friend just one because they'll be like
i don't care about your politics and i'm
like oh we can just hang out and play
basketball what was the spark where you
realized something was amiss
i mean i did before my
life fell apart it was when i would hang
out with prominent liberals and they
would talk a certain way and say that
certain things were silly and then they
would go to their twitter and say the
opposite and that's why i'm like oh
we're
we're lying um it was when the first
time i talked to people who were more
conservative or libertarians
were people of color
at my jujitsu gym where when i went to
like staff meetings of liberal
publications their get-togethers in like
park slope brooklyn it was very very
white and very very privileged hey all
that stuff you're saying it applies to
this room and they're like shut up yeah
yeah get out but it was that it was
they'll be tweeting about black lives
matter as they're walking down the
street and they're like oh black person
across the street across the street
across the street like it was just uh it
was the hypocrisy this is sweden in my
experience to the tea because i went to
sweden do you remember that uh when
donald trump said you know the last
night in sweden thing
do you remember that
so this was back in 2017 there was a
documentary that came up on fox or like
a short talking about crime going up in
sweden
i go there and i find that a lot of the
claims are largely exaggerated and
didn't understand the complexities of
sweden but what i did find is that
people in sweden are
so many of them not all of them but so
much of their culture was very much in
advance of how the us was
they are over like they're scandinavian
white people talking about how not
racist they are and then trying
everything in their power to keep black
people away from them because they were
just
they they wanted people to think they
weren't racist
but they were really racist but i should
also say maybe that's actually wrong
maybe i should say culturist
because they didn't like people who
didn't speak their language they didn't
like people who didn't look like them so
it was not just race it was even even
white people who didn't speak you know
swedish they'd be like well we don't
want to work with you it's just we don't
we don't want you around they're just
d-bags in general i'm thinking like if
you're raised if i was raised in like a
tribe in africa with people with darker
skin tone or whatever that i then i
would be weirded out by people with
light skin tone if i saw not necessarily
weirded out but like it's a familiarity
bias i don't even know what racism is
like i think racism small r and racism
big are big r is where you're like
you're different than me it's you know
racial slur and where a small r
maybe is more classist i don't know but
but this again this is america this is
the only majority white country that's
elected the black president there is a
sociologist at harvard all sociologists
are left-wing his name is his name is
orlando patterson he's black and in the
90s he says america is the least racist
majority white society in the world
provides more opportunities for blacks
in any society in the world including
all of those of africa
when my i want to tell you a quick story
jamie when my when my race was over
i'm in a restaurant in l.a on the west
side and i get there and my buddy hasn't
arrived yet and there's a table next to
me with two ladies and i think they feel
sorry for me yeah so they started
talking to me
and they were 85 years old they'd known
each other since the second grade they
were jewish one was a human rights
activist whatever that means the other
one was a psychotherapist yeah
and then about 15 minutes after the
conversation one of them said wait a
minute i know who you are
you're that guy that ran for governor
i said that's right and she had a big
smile she said guess who i voted for so
you didn't vote for me and she said how
do you know that i said let's see uh
we're in the west side of la you're both
jewish one of you is a human rights
activist it doesn't take colombo to put
that together you didn't vote for me and
she said no you're right i didn't i said
how do you feel about the about the
crime and she said i have a friend who
got mugged he told me about that that's
how you feel about the quality of our
schools she said i would never put my
kids in a public school how do you feel
about the way gavin newsom shut down the
state in a more severe way than anybody
else did sitting up there at that
restaurant not wearing a mask not
engaging in social differences with the
people that drafted the mandates had his
own kids in person she said i thought
was hypocritical how do you feel about
the fact that people leaving california
so they agree with me on everything
i said so here we are completing each
other's sentences yet you wouldn't vote
for me do you have any republican
friends at all and they look at each
other and they admitted that they didn't
they said this is the first time you've
ever had a conversation with somebody
who's conservative isn't it and they
both said yes i mean honestly yeah talk
about they talk about you just in a
cocoon you should just call them racists
bigots
all those things you said were
conservative alt-right talking and then
be like buy my book and just throw it
and then and then they bought my drinks
and bought my dinner yeah that's what i
wanted well and and and that's the thing
i ordered lobster i think it was
lobster of course
i don't even like lobster
yeah i think one of the most insidious
words um is when if you change your mind
you're called a grifter and i've made
jokes about this i've made jokes about
it on cass castle um on the podcast
because essentially it's saying that
if you evolve a viewpoint if you step
out of your bubble if you you know i
mean i didn't i expected when i came on
this show that i would just kind of be
like token liberal guy make jokes um
make fun of myself all done and i've
been
fascinated at
how my a lot of my views have changed
and not because you know tim hired me
when i was like liberal liberal liberal
um
my views have changed because i'm just
talking to different people
which we should all be doing and in fact
when i talk to some conservative friends
and i still give some of my bleeding
heart points of view they go man i never
thought of that either and that's good
as well you're not grifting you're
growing this is what i try to explain to
people you're you're searching for the
truth i'm searching for the truth that's
what you are yes and if you have that i
don't care if you're a republican
malcolm x said i'm for the truth no
matter who's telling it yes and that's
how i feel yep i i'm willing to change
my mind make me change my give me the
facts give me something i've said wrong
thought wrong and i will change my mind
my god i got excited when you quoted
malcolm x okay you know let's go back
and focus one thing you've got to be
careful of is love bombs from getting
this new crowd of followers oh we talked
about that with the marjorie taylor
green where uh every time now uh i get a
compliment they're like we're love
bombing you jamie and i'm like i know
because it feels good to get accepted it
does
well and and look man i still see a lot
of stuff i'll tweet like an innocuous
joke about you know something i saw
that day and you know i know people who
found me on here like will just start
like ranting about biden and i'm like
okay bud like you can take it down i'm
not a biden fan but i think that look
when you start changing your mind
because you're being accepted no good if
you're doing it for a paycheck that's
where the term grifter makes sense if
you are asking questions to people on
the left and to people on the right and
your only goal like you said larry is
just to find the truth or like dude i
just want people to
start coming up with solutions and i
know that if we're screaming at that's
why my questions to you
were all about like hey how do we get
people to talk about this hey take
politics out what do you what are you
telling someone who's struggling how do
you act as a man like forget what party
you are let me let me actually ask you
then i guess uh uh uh
the next step in the question of
solutions
if the perception is that people are
unwilling to listen they're
hyper-tribalized your friends of 40
years i think you said was it 40 years
wouldn't even read an article
where do you think this is all heading
well
there's a certain percentage of people
that you have to write off
they will not listen they do not care uh
they're locked into their positions i'm
not sure what the percentage of that is
there was a 2002 uh fox opinion poll
eight percent of americans believe elvis
is still alive
six percent believe if you send him a
letter you'll get it now it seems to me
that
eight percent just gotta you just gotta
you know just write them off i think
most people are pursuing their own
own owned personal interests uh they
want to realize their god-given
potential i think most people do that
and if you are persistent and you say
things in a persuasive in a persuasive
way
simply i think most people will at least
listen to you at least i operate on
under that assumption and you have to
operate under that assumption other than
what how do you get up in the morning
and just go half the country is is
irredeemable i'm going to avoid that
right i just can't do that and i won't
do that you guys said earlier like the
truth that you're both seeking the truth
i get nervous about that because i feel
like it's subjective to um and that
there's no absolute truth it's facts you
could say there are facts but the way
you look at the fact is the your version
of the fact well either either donald
either donald trump mocked the handicap
reporter or he didn't either donald
trump said there were good nazis in bad
nazis in charlottesville or he didn't
these are just facts he did not do that
he did not mock a reporter yet yet much
of the country believes that
uh
i don't believe in this i'll tell you my
truth there is a truth uh often it's
hard to find and often things are gray
but there are certain things that
happened and didn't happen two plus two
equal four i don't care how how you feel
well wait a second what's your second
order
and then it's i think it's what your
sexual orientation is two plus two still
equals four yeah i think that um
you know
a piece of relationship advice i
actually give that i think we could
really use when it comes to politics is
if me and ian are in a relationship and
we get in a fight and all i want to do
is prove that ian's wrong and all he
wants to do is prove that i'm wrong
nothing's going to get accomplished you
know even sometimes by the time let's
say i apologized then maybe even ian
throws in something like yeah we should
apologize you really hurt me i was like
oh man we're still going and i think
that if you're in a fight with your
girlfriend or boyfriend or whoever
if
you can just focus on hey what can i
what could i have done better even if
i'm in even if clearly my girlfriend was
in the wrong right right and i'm just
like well i guess i could have reacted
better and then i get to bring that to
the table and she brings that what she
did wrong to the table now we both grow
i wish that republicans could hold
themselves accountable more liberals
could hold themselves accountable more
and instead of just attack attack attack
it could just be hey how do we get
better and again i don't even i think
you got to listen to the people you
don't like that's what it is it's heroic
of course like the truth is factual but
the way people feel is how you convince
so
people want to i think some people maybe
want to just lay it on the facts and be
like this is the truth but if you don't
feel what they feel about it then it's
not the word true doesn't really ring
you have to connect with them on like a
human level i i think i'm sure you've
learned that in years of of radio and
speaking where it's yeah if you're just
shouting facts at someone who disagrees
with you you're right they could totally
tune out but if you can actually connect
with them as a person through like
stories like the stories you tell about
your friends i go oh i've had a friend
i've had to walk away from from that and
you feel it you can connect to it and
then you can listen
my mom used to say the truth will not
set you free if delivered without hope
oh that's a good point that's beautiful
i want to jump to this story and
announcement
uh ladies and gentlemen timcast.com is
officially news guard certified let's go
they gave us a score of an 82 out of
100.
uh the reason i think this warrants a
story is why they gave us an x on one
issue of gathering and presenting
information responsibly
to put it simply
we adhere to all standards of newsguard
for those that are not familiar
newsguard is a certification agency that
rates all news organizations it is used
by big tech companies to determine
whether or not you can share the content
or it gets seen by others
because in about five stories out of
four thousand it's 300 3 892 stories
five of them had issues
one of them i believe was a fact issue
two of them were for quoting the
president himself and two were because
we had sentences that were just a little
too similar to other organizations even
though the sentences themselves were
quite generic the reason why this is
irrelevant
this affects how we get viewed on
facebook if you share one of our
articles this is how the cathedral
operates we use newsguard as a as a bias
checker on our own it's also a shield if
we report a story that says how about
this the hunter biden laptop was
confirmed and the emails in it are are
known to be real
well if someone tries claiming we're
spreading consideracy conspiracy
conspiracy theories i need only look to
the daily mail and the new york post who
are certified by news guard and said
this is true and then i can say take it
up with that certified agency used by
big tech companies
they claimed that because in two
articles we did a fact-based report
donald trump says quote in response to
quote that because we didn't run a fact
check we are irresponsible and sharing
misleading information because as
newsguard said trump's quotes were
provably false i said okay how about
this
we weren't doing a fact check article we
were just reporting the news but if you
want moving forward we will include a
fact check here's where it gets really
funny as i stated this is what the
institution the cathedral uses it's
funded by i believe microsoft and bill
uh bill gates particularly or people
mention that it may just be microsoft
in the nutrition label and again i i
have to stress this because
this is what they they consider to be
the standard for for big tech
they had four errors outright
incorrectly labeling my job at tim cast
at vice and at fusion
falsely labeling the uh tales from the
inverted world as science fiction and
fantasy they corrected all of those
immediately only after i told them they
made the mistake
they injected opinion referring to cast
castle as mundane and the best part of
the whole thing is that's the most
offensive part at all thank you yeah
it's hilarious i think it's stellar work
they have injected a false quote from me
which has to be the most egregious thing
and this is what i want to say and i
wanted to be on the record and forgive
me if it's a bit internal or esoteric to
the industry
when you have an organization that
violates its own standards and accuses
you of being irresponsible well now we
have uh the fbi i'm just kidding by the
way perhaps yes well you've got an issue
there
so let me uh
i want to show you this they say asked
by news guard about the above
unchallenged claims this was because we
quoted that we said donald trump says
quote
in an email pool said we will institute
a policy immediately on all quotes
moving uh here's what they wrote on all
quotes bracket that are false bracket
moving forward to run fact checks and
we'll have those two articles updated
immediately i never said that nor did i
imply it quite the opposite i told
newsguard that if you require us to to
run a fact check on donald trump's
quotes the policy would require us to
fact check every single quote from
anyone we ever report on and we will do
that if that's what your standard
dictates that would put newsguard in an
impossible situation and potentially put
them in civil tort liability positions
so they injected a false quote from me
that said that are false which i never
said
i have requested a correction twice now
on that false quote they have not
corrected it
so but tim they did not call you the
black face of white supremacy now that's
special
so give them that that should be the
blurb
this is the standard by which the media
operates it is impossible standard to be
that being said an 82 out of 100 is one
of the highest ratings you can probably
get we got one ding but we have five
articles out of three thousand eight
hundred and ninety two this needs to be
said so that you all understand for one
i am already preparing litigation
newsguard you are being warned okay i
will be very distinct and clear give me
standing against wikipedia and i will
launch a lawsuit in two seconds and put
my money where my mouth is newsguard you
want to claim we are irresponsible
here's what they claimed because they
alerted us to five articles and we
didn't catch them that means we're
irresponsible i got six errors from you
on your own website if your standard is
that we have to be more responsible than
you are i'd love to see you file that in
court so i can parade it around after we
file if you don't correct this also what
are the news organizations that led us
into war with iraq what are their
ratings 100 out of 100 ladies and
gentlemen i give you usa today usa today
receives a 100 out of 100 credibility
rating despite the fact that on their on
their page they say in june 2022 usa
today took down nearly two dozen stories
by a reporter whom the newspaper said
appeared to have made up people she
quoted newsguard fabric fabricated a
quote from me
they cl they even acknowledge usa today
fabricated stories but they are 100 out
of 100. also i would argue
that this has to put them in some kind
of uh uh civil tort territory
i will show every single certification
they've ever given and i will show they
have no legitimate standards and i want
them in court to admit it
usa today drove that story several years
ago that black churches were being
burned because of racism and it turned
out completely totally bogus there were
more mosques and synagogues that were
burned
most of the black churches that were
burned were in the forest in the woods
very few of them were burned as a result
of somebody doing it because of racism
completely set this whole country part
in the expression on fire the story was
completely and totally bogus
i am just learning that today in 2022.
and what what did they say about us we
quoted trump but didn't include context
challenging trump which by the way which
is misleading you as a a a news
organization quoting the president of
the united states either way whether
trump was right or wrong is still
covering the news and it is certainly
certainly uh less nefarious than
newsguard purposefully misquoting you i
will i will add this is part of what
gives them the credibility as their
agency but i want to stress that it's
used by these big tech companies but i
also want to stress the purpose here is
to show you what their standard is when
they claim the new york times is factual
when they claim that usa today's factual
they emailed me saying this is this is
you're going to love this guys because
we didn't talk too much about this
before i'm going to flip the table first
thing they tried getting us on saying
these are our fake news was that the
hunter biden laptop story they said you
claimed that hunter biden in an email
was seeking funding for bio labs or
whatever and i said well i didn't claim
that the daily mail in the new york post
did and they said that's not been
verified i said i'm sorry you certified
the daily mail and the new york post as
credible agencies which i used in my
assessment of their fact statements
would you like to now have on the record
that you don't consider your own
certifications to be viable they
immediately responded with this one's
too murky so we're going to ignore it
and i said you refuse to admit that
you're you're challenging your own
certifications
i will i you you got to understand guys
this is a this this culture war and the
issues we're facing with censorship are
deeper than just
one story about elon musk and twitter of
course they are and behind the scenes i
want i want to let you all know people
are saying like why don't you do more
put your money where your mouth is
if i i have harped on wikipedia for
defamator defamation because wikipedia
says from wikipedia on every article
that is a byline
i don't have standing to sue them you
need standing and you need injury
correct me if i'm wrong is that that's
correct why don't you have standing they
did not defame me
wikipedia their article about me is
actually
fairly neutral or opinion
veritas i believe wikipedia is i'm not
james so i don't know for sure but i
believe it's verifiably false what
they've published which means they would
have standing and then what they need to
do is challenge wikipedia's 230
protections under the grounds that
they've put their byline on the article
right not the users
as for newsguard i have done everything
to make sure that anything they do
grants me standing so i can make sure
they have to file in court why they're
lying have no standards or are factually
incorrect and then i will
we'll just leave it at that for the time
being now i like news guard in that
if they i like i like in the in the res
in the respect that
we'll use them and i'll say don't look
at me they're the ones certifying it
i'll pass the buck to them that's what
they are the responsibilities they are
taking and i can respect that but don't
come to me and tell me there is no
standard by which we can be deemed a
credible news organization when you have
lower standards for other organizations
that i find to be slanderous and
defamatory and the fact that they
fabricated a quote from me crossed the
line i was content with saying they need
to correct this earlier today until i
read they fabricated a quote for me to
protect their asses
did they take a quote and then add stuff
to it yup what did they add exactly they
added bracket that was false to imply oh
bracket so they're assuming you implied
that which is also i believe
i would argue maybe even grounds for
malice because what i actually said was
it's an impossible standard but we'll do
it
to add those words is to imply my
statement was actually that we will
begin fact-checking false statements
that we weren't fact-checking before but
i mean it is to imply that i was
accepting false statements
no so we have a corrections policy and
we don't allow false statements but you
can't know if something's false until
after you fact check it exactly it's
ridiculous because they knew my
statement to be included would show that
they have have broken standards they
they put a fake quote in place
i'm not standing for that
i have some basis for a lawsuit after my
campaign for governor i was just a
scotch under a million followers on
twitter
over the next several months i lost
about 30 000 and i still lose about 100
per day however a few weeks ago when
elon musk announced his intention to buy
twitter i gained 10 000 followers within
24 hours how does that happen you're not
alone how does i know uh and a lot of
conservatives gained a lot of and a lot
of liberals lost a lot of followers in
one fell swoop within 24 48 hours that
is some severe nega some malpractice
tell me about it
something something
we're going to go to that's like a class
action thing
i've got to we're going to super chats
but um youtube has been breaking on us
so
before we do larry what's your mom's
name because i want to attribute that
quote to her viola elder can you say
that quote one more time like like the
instrument yeah do you want to say it
the truth will not set you free if
delivered without hope yes so we've been
my my husband and i have been having an
ongoing conversation over whether facts
care about your feelings and i argue
that you can't convince someone of a
fact unless you also care about the
feelings it's kind of like what maya
angelou said she said people will you
know forget what you said don't forget
what you did but they'll never forget
my mother couldn't stand maya angelou
yeah and i understand i thought she was
phony yes by the way you know you know
she's not a doctor they call her a
doctor she's in no degree oh really my
mother thought she was completely phoned
he thought her accent was all made up
she my mother couldn't stand her yes can
you guys call me doctor from now on
so i don't like to use that my angelou
quote because i don't like her either
but i think she has a point and that
people don't really care if you're
presenting them with facts if you appear
to not care about how they feel right
now well that's why comedy can be so
powerful right it's like it evokes a
physical feeling and then if you can
laugh together chances are you can
figure some stuff out and it would be
nice it's nice if late night comedy
wasn't so far to the left well it's only
one it's great the only one that late
night that that that is not left-wing
yeah
and about 15 of young people admit that
they get their primary source of news
from the monologues larry i would like
to argue that they are also not funny so
not technically compliance
well we're going to go to super chats if
you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button and subscribe to
this channel we are going to have the
members only uncensored after hours show
that will be published on the website
timcast.com at about 11 p.m stick around
for that let's read some super chats
youtube imploded but we found a way to
make sure we can get through as many as
we can
we've got
how to say late night hvac says desantis
elder 2024.
i'm liking it
where do i sign i'm making no
announcement but where do i sign
all right let's see
lord blueberry says is that the black
face of white supremacy i see that's
what the other for the early times call
me her name her initials are erica d
smith oops
when i ran she ran a column and the
headline was ian larry elder is the
black face of white supremacy
sub-headline you've been warned
there's another columnist with the other
times named gene guerrero who referred
to my views as white supremacist what
did you say that made people think tell
me about it i invited erica smith on my
show when the when the campaign was over
to explain it she wouldn't come on
right
to have a smiley interview with him a
black host who was on pbs for years i
remember tavis smiley and he referred to
me in my interview as anti-black i said
tavis why am i anti-black what view do i
have this anti-black he said you're
opposed to reparations i said obama was
opposed to reparation until a year ago
was he anti-black until a year ago you
know i'm open to repairing things but i
don't think throwing money at the
problem is the way to repair systems we
need a holistic re-function of our
monetary so furthermore if you're
talking about reparations i mean who
should pay reparations
flavor was the democratic party
democrats owned slaves republicans
didn't only about five percent have some
sort of generational connection to
slavery so all the people that came here
uh after after the civil war world war
one world war ii they should be paying
into it it's ridiculous it was 150 years
ago uh and and furthermore
without the complicity of african
chieftains slavery could not have taken
place they they aided the european slave
trade the islamic slave trade after we
pay reparations then go to africa and
get money from that and and and and get
get reimbursed from africans because of
this you see native american chieftains
made bank when they sold out their
tribes to the settlers they did it let's
read let's do more we've got siege she
says some of my earliest memories are
listening to the sage from south central
on kabc in the mid 90s driving out with
my dad we've got a country to save now
more than ever
one of my standard lines we've got a
country to save wow yep
i got a lot of lines all right sideways
the great old dursky
the czar of common sense don
lorenzo sideways says ian i finally
understand your views in the federal
reserve i watched a mini documentary on
it and had no idea they were a private
entity and that they really have more
power than lawmakers that's awesome
watching that documentary is it's so
nuts dude when you start to figure out
what the [ __ ] is going on you look so
vindicated when tim was reading that i
was very excited
people are waking up
and they're printing money like crazy
yeah i mean on the books 27 trillion
what's off the books i
and the whole point behind the federal
reserve is was to avoid depressions and
recessions we've had many of them since
they've been around and you could argue
that they are the ones that caused it i
think we need an audit of the federal
reserve which is going to lead to a
repeal of the federal reserve act
perhaps here we go
siobhan young says larry i love thomas
sowell so could you tell me your opinion
of james b stewart's critique of black
rednecks and white liberals it's the
only academic critique i could find of
him i messaged your show about this a
while back i don't remember what what
james stewart said about it i love the
book
um i don't know what the criticism is
well then so i'll take a pass on that
one do you think with the i mean
kind of on the same subject with the
the accusations of being a white
supremacist i can't believe i just said
that to your face i couldn't even make
eye contact with you okay come on jamie
i worked hard for that time yeah okay
sorry sorry sorry please
well it's an honor to meet you
um do you
i mean man like hearing you explain
these views
long form on this show
it's
you're not saying racism doesn't exist
so let's leave the problem alone you're
offering solutions to help black
communities and so if you're trying to
still help the black communities even if
people on the left don't agree with you
that's not white supremacism it would be
white
supremacism if you were like get them
out of it why can't we have a discussion
about that yes you know jamie over the
years i will get a letter from somebody
or somebody will call my show and say
now larry you say racism doesn't exist
but let me tell you something i said 100
000 to your favorite charity where you
can find where larry elder wrote or ever
said racism doesn't exist right i've
never said that the fact that i believe
that racism is no longer a major problem
in america does not believe does that
mean i don't believe it exists i've
never said that how do you get from that
to that right right i think it's like
roman supremacy people get really
sometimes they get fired up when i talk
about the roman empire but i feel like
the romans or the slaveocracy tried to
conquer the world then they built a
church in this roman catholic church now
is like still in control of people's
minds and
white or black it don't matter man when
there's a when there's a group of
consciousness that's attempting to
control things
there's there i definitely think that
there is a you know the jesuit like the
the the black pope you want to look at
the power of the pope and the black pope
and what what the jesuits are doing
go down that rabbit hole let's read this
one we got from sam samuel adams ah
thanks for the super chat sam adams
because brian kill me uh kill me tweeted
just spoke to eric trump nothing in the
safe fbi agents 30 approximately rated
on behalf of national archives has to
come from potus or someone in the white
house
so perhaps this is related to the the
story about trump tearing up notes and
flushing them in the toilet or something
it would have been funny if trump just
left a note in the safe and it was like
can't catch me
the funny thing is that story where they
claim that trump was tearing up notes
and put him in the toilet there are
pictures of them who took those pictures
who went into the bathroom after trump
to take pictures of what was in the
toilet is very strange right and the
fact that trump would put notes in the
toilet and not flush is also strange
trump being like hey come fill me
destroy evidence sure yeah creating more
evidence or someone's like hey hey trump
just went to the bathroom go take
pictures what that's weird too unless he
like walked in and just flicked it in
there
trump does seem like the kind of guy who
would be like take a picture well the
white house trump is the kind of guy who
turns around takes a picture
the white house is a very old building
maybe you have a bad plumbing system
yeah yeah yeah
out of the your tax dollars at work
[Laughter]
all right let's see we can grab from
these super chats
shinobi strong side it says or it's
shinobi strong said ignorance having the
capacity and access to relevant
information and consciously choosing to
ignore it not to be confused with
nessience
oh they say ignorance is knowing but
choosing to ignore it as opposed to
messians interesting well messy i think
ignorance is just lacking knowledge how
do you spell messians and he sees
science
thank you
all right
pop up up we're gonna grab some i'm
trying to find some good questions for
for larry
yeah
all right a lot of people are really
really angry about the fbi
adam horage says to mr elder i don't
trust government to do well with m with
many societal problems what charities
are fixing the functional literacy issue
you mentioned i'll donate what i can to
a good charity oh that's awesome well
there are a lot of
private
schools there are a lot of pro-choice
organizations that
have been set up there are a lot of
charities that are very efficient for
three months i volunteered for the
united way once
for every dollar that government spends
on welfare about 70 cents is burned in
transfer costs rent those kinds of
things every dollar donated to an
organization like united way 85 gets
down to the intended beneficiary because
most people like i was are voluntary so
there are lots of organizations go
online and find them
right on
all rights also shout out for being like
i'm going to donate instead of violence
in the streets
that's what you do support organizations
there's an organization called
brotherhood of a new destiny led by
reverend jesse lee peterson uh and he
coaches men who don't have fathers to
reconcile with their fathers or to lose
their anger so they can go forward wow
bond brotherhood of a new destiny wow
that's the beginning okay what do you
think i mean this is probably a basic
question that you get when you talk
about fatherhood because i was really
captivated by that and
you know obviously there are a lot of
marriages that are horrifically
dysfunctional right so
what's the advice you give or the
solution for
you know is it better to have
um
a single mom who loves you
unconditionally who crushes it who's
doing everything she can then an
incredibly abusive
um marriage that now you're watching and
that's shaping that's not even a close
call obviously it's better to have a
mother that loves you than a
dysfunctional angry violent marriage
yeah again the whole point behind
watching your mom and your dad is to
watch them resolve disappearance yes
without anger without rancar without
violence if you don't see that and you
see it resolve violently you're gonna
behave that way as well right all right
you wanna go i was gonna add one thing a
um
a poor black kid with mother and father
will have a better outcome in life than
a middle-class white kid with just a mom
yeah
robert poynter says larry elder's dad's
advice is legendary i'm going to
re-listen to that multiple times so i
can quote that to my seven and
four-year-old sons great show
amazing what's your dad's name randolph
randolph elder ever go by randy he does
go by randy yeah randolph elder
r-a-n-d-o-l-p-h and the book again is
called the hardback is called dear
father dear son two lives eight hours
and the paperback is called a lot like
me i'm trying to get the book made into
a movie we already have a deal uh i have
a really strong agent and one of their
clients is denzel washington and i'm
just envisioning denzel washington
oh my goodness
denzel if you're listening ted zell you
know how to reach me yeah chris also
come on the vlog that's right chris van
dern
i believe it says dern says larry your
story had me crying it's both
heartbreaking and heartwarming if only
we could uh we could all have that kind
of understanding many of our problems
would disappear and we could tackle
bigger issues
my brothers as i mentioned disliked my
father as intensely as i did that's why
i didn't think it was me i thought it
was him my little brother died years ago
he was diabetic but after i reconciled
with my dad i contacted my older brother
kirk and i said kirk that's not an
a-hole he's not he's not what you think
oh yes he is no he's not oh yes he is
kirk you got to sit down with the man
i'm not going to talk to him so a couple
weeks later i'm over visiting my dad i
said dad did uh have you talked to kirk
lately he said yeah why'd you ask i said
i just wondered he said he came over
here we had a five-hour conversation my
brother never told me until my dad told
me man this is the exact same thing we
were talking about with politics because
i remember i it was my brother that
convinced me to talk to my dad i hated
my dad and i i actually had a story in
one of my old stand-up cds all about
that moment when you realized that the
reason that you hated your parents is
because they were decent people they
were doing their job and that's supposed
to be your buddy and it was the exact
same thing where i was like dad was such
a jerk he didn't want me to play in like
a band and my brother was like hey man
do you remember what dad's day to day
looked like and then just mapped out
waking up at four making us breakfast
driving two hours to all this stuff and
you just go oh
god like it was for me i realized it was
it was me you know and and if people
could so much of it just has to do with
ego and being right and being married to
these stories whether it's well i grew
up democrat or whether it's why i grew
up hating my dad or whatever story you
tell yourself or whether for the people
listening with mental health stuff like
if it's
your story about you being a bad person
or you being a failure they're all
stories man and you can overcome when i
was writing the book my dad was alive he
died as soon as i finished the book and
as i was writing it i would ask him
questions about what did you do here
why'd you do this yeah and he said why
are you writing a book about my little
life i said dad your life wasn't little
it was epic you just don't know it
all right we got this from curtis
mclaughlin jr he says mr elder the goat
by the way i was recently arrested for
loitering and prowling while eating taco
bell in a parking lot
inadvertent participation in the justice
system can happen charges dropped didn't
say it didn't couldn't have yeah there
was a guy
his name first name was charles and he
was at a beverly hills restaurant goes
out to put money in the parking meter he
doesn't want his car told away and he's
surrounded by cops and he's and he's uh
arrested handcuffed and urged to sit on
the curb for about 45 minutes while they
sort out whether or not he is a bank
robber turns out the bank robber was
wearing the same color pants same
colored shirt was a black man who was
bald had the same roughly the same
complexion he even admitted it but he
cooperated and sat there even though he
knew he hadn't done anything yeah and
that's that's the lesson there's no
point in fighting with these guys they
have guns
oh also sorry brother i didn't mean to
laugh at you it's just my flight got
delayed last night and i got into one
like one in the morning and i shamefully
went to a taco bell drive-through and it
looked like i was i felt like a prowler
too i was just like i'm garbage i had i
had back-to-back flights that were that
were delayed i get here to dc and my
luggage doesn't come down i go to the
little area and she goes on the computer
does something i don't know what yeah
and she says
do you have a firearm in your life
i said a what she said a gun and
everybody goes he's got a gun
and
she said we put the luggage with
firearms in here so check and see if
it's in here and it was there right so
i'm taking it out there's a guy that
checks the tag to make sure it's my
suitcase and i said somebody's going to
ask me if there's you want to search the
things these are the fire armor because
we're good
so you took my word for it took my word
for it wasn't one in there you don't
even want to look and see oh wow did you
go to taco bell talk about top security
yeah all right yeah neo reaper says
thoughts on andrew yang and the forward
party and the which party forward party
hadn't heard about it you know andrew
yang i know yeah he ran for mayor he ran
for brantford governor run for president
i like that upgrading
i think a smart guy like him
yeah he's a third party he's the one a
little his little thing on they said
math yeah yeah yeah anyone who can shake
stuff up i'm here for yeah
all right
box fed tv says tim all my super chats
have called out the fbi last week i told
whitaker he was weak uh oh whitaker
right today we'll live in infamy every
republican must call for the complete
dismantling of the fbi new trump uh
trump rally chant and the fbi
defund the fbi yeah
i like that also see you when you're
being raided by the fbi buddy
liberty this is really a scary
development no kidding that the funded
thing was a joke but it's really really
quite scary yeah oh yeah
this is the kind of thing look
when when you read about history
and people talk about fleeing countries
this is one of the things people would
say like why did you before before the
bad thing happened like why did your
family leave and they were like well
when they raided the the previous
president's home and started arresting
him we knew things were getting bad
take a look at ukraine
a few years ago
they they ousted yanukovych the
president and then people stormed into
his house and started looting and
stealing stuff
so i don't know where we're going from
here but when the doj
makes moves like this
you're living history man by the way we
don't know whether trump was home at
mar-a-lago no he's in bedminster or he's
not exactly here so i believe he's up in
new jersey
uh but either way this is when they
announced trump's actions were being
investigated
i'm like that doesn't mean they're
investigating trump so it could be that
they're trying to pull back they don't
want to come out and announce they are
doing it because it would shock people
or they're not really doing it they want
it to seem like they are to try and hurt
him
this
could still be argued
they're like a search warrant for
someone else because mar-a-lago's
massive and they're trying to just make
it look like trump is going down for
something but either way at this point
it doesn't matter whatever you think it
is the president's home was just raided
by a former president was rated by the
feds
alright
let's grab some more super chats as we
move forward here i think we can jump
over to the actual super chats now
all right all right
we get this this weird thing happens
where youtube's crashed recently and
then it erases the super chats
they're still there but we were able we
were able to pull them up morgan dawson
says i was an army cook i'm now a
private chef
in uh
let's say
in white and the majority of my army
buddies are black oh i'm white and the
majority of my army buddies are black
and hispanic i've been out for 10 years
but they gave me a call i'm on the move
to help if they gave me a call on the
move to help i'll still risk my life for
my brothers and sisters
right i'm glad to hear it
all right
musically assured destruction says
should law enforcement in metro areas be
run like sheriffs elected by citizens
that way they are truly held accountable
to the people also great screen name
buddy yeah i'd say so
you can argue it both ways um
also they're accountable to the people
and the people can be emotional like the
people in the streets yelling and
screaming about
the man that shot through that
door in baltimore and the people in the
streets were yelling black lives matter
black lives matter you could get a bunch
of people who are emotionally disturbed
about something and they're wrong
and they vote for the wrong person yeah
so it's hard to say right right i could
argue either way
scott says tim what happens if a red
wave doesn't happen larry you're an
inspiration sir uh what do you think
happens if we don't get a red wave as i
said before i think we're spiking the
football too soon uh the polls are
tightening up as you pointed out there
used to be a big almost a double-digit
lead in the generic poll for republicans
not anymore is now gone and you look at
kamala harris matched up against donald
trump or against uh desantis and she's
competitive so it may very well not
happen and again the media or you know
interpreting anything that happens uh if
if donald trump expelled gas in the in
the pantry in the white house uh it was
covered negatively when joe biden does
something it's not covered nearly as
negatively hey what would you
i should i i i didn't ask uh marjorie
taylor green this but i will ask you
this um what
what would you change about the
republican party like what's your both
part if you had to critique like your
own party what would it be both parties
spend too much money
if and when the republicans take over in
november the house and the senate
we should have a amendment to the
constitution that fix spending to a
certain percentage of the gdp with
exception for war and for natural
disaster otherwise both parties expand
government it expanded under george w
bush expanded under ronald reagan he ran
to shut down the department of education
when he left it was bigger than before
both parties spend money and we've got
to stop it great thank you
all right
brian david says i grew up with no sense
of alliance or support the lessons of
the leftist indoctrination failed to
take root other than the attitude and
tactics how do i improve myself and
bring love into my heart and my life
psilocybin
i mean what would you say i would just
say i would just say keep your eyes open
uh
in ingest the news discriminate
with discrimination and with judgment uh
and uh try to be the best person that
you can
are you religious i am i my pastor is
pastor jack hibbs he's one of the four
people
uh who really influenced my decision to
run for office all right yeah i and i
think i think it's hard it's to me it's
difficult for people to really
understand
right and wrong without a religious
foundation you have to understand that
there's evil in the world and a lot of
people on the left just don't seem to
understand that because they're not
they're not
god-centered
i just wanted to
shout that person out because your last
line
you asking that question
you're already doing more than the
majority of people do so you being
self-aware you looking for
ways to lead with love
you're on the right path and i would say
as someone who has really really
struggled um in his life and with mental
health stuff
one of the best pieces of advice i can
give is hold yourself accountable but
when you do good
give yourself credit like you looking
for this you seeking more knowledge and
ways to lead with love and you know i
mean one of the things i've started
doing is i heard this great quote where
even when you're driving in traffic
where it's treating every car like it's
the dalai lama driving where it's like
catch yourself catch yourself when
you're judging someone catch yourself
when you're uh drawing conclusions catch
yourself when you're being selfish and
don't get mad at yourself when you do it
or else you're going to spiral but
slowly correct and get better and better
better try faster don't beat up on
yourself when you make mistakes because
we all make them you have to my favorite
movie is no country for an old man you
see the movie great it's a brutal movie
it's brutal
there's a scene where tommy lee jones
goes up to the sheriff in the wheelchair
because he wants advice on what to do
and he says to him the man that put you
in the wheelchair is about ready to get
out of prison possibly if he does what
are you going to do about it and the guy
that will just said probably nothing
and tommy said i'm surprised to hear you
say that and he said when you try to get
back what ben took from you moore's
going out the door all the time pretty
soon you just got to put a tourniquet on
it wow
i wonder i invite that guy to try
fasting too because when you clear your
gut out you become more in tune with
your feelings all right yeah do
challenging things giovanta says mr
elder carries the tradition of booker t
washington who advocated for self-help
entrepreneurship and vocational training
unfortunately black politicians believe
more in w.e.b dubois right and the ta
and the talent what does it say talented
tenth talented tenth which perpetuates
an elite ideology could you elaborate on
absolutely and in fact we we explore the
differences between the two in uncle tom
one and we get into it a little more
deeply in uncle tom too booker t
washington believed uh when a negro boy
learns to cook to sow to wash dishes or
to practice medicine as well as or
better than somebody else he or she will
be rewarded without regard to race uh
and um uh wd boyce was all about
uh
an elite kind of attitude and and uh
they used a quarrel
so and and the boys ultimately rejected
the american citizenship became a
communist and moved to russia
uh booker t washington's tuskegee
institution is still here so whose
vision really ended up being the vision
that was correct
also uncle tom you can see at uncle
tom.com right now for free hitting you
back for that check and then chattanooga
the documentary
the things i i learned about herman cain
i did not know and uh his story about
his time and i think his time in the
military and and how he improved himself
man that was absolutely incredible dude
it's been a while since i watched it
i uh i'm going to say something that i'm
uncomfortable saying but it's just it's
such an opportunity i think i need to
which is i think that
the second that people on the left and
this is so
patronizing and gross and it's the worst
part about what people say the left is
um when they hear a black conservative
without actually listening to them or
reading them i've never read thomas i've
never read your books i'm gonna get your
books when i go home um
is this idea that kind of similar to the
grifter where it's all you're doing is
you're giving racist an excuse to
essentially be the black friend right so
when someone does something or they're
accused of racism they could be like oh
i'm not racist like i've read larry
elder i've read thomas or whatever what
do you say to that critique because
again i just see a very authentic human
being who is trying to solve a problem
maybe differently than i would have
thought in the past but you haven't said
much that i've been like oh gross i
disagree with that um but what do you
say to that as this idea that someone
who clearly cares about black people is
just and by the way there might be do
you feel responsible for people who are
racist and they'll throw your name
around to be like racism isn't real like
go read larry elder
no i i don't feel responsible because
racism is no longer a major problem in
america and if somebody quotes me as
saying that i'm fine with that i think
you're wrong on that one
i think racism is still a big problem in
this country it's just not the same kind
of racism
so you have affirmative action for
instance discriminatory policies you've
got democrats trying to strip out civil
rights provisions but i'm being a bit
pedantic i would i would i would i would
say
dude we're all brains floating
discriminating discrimination to fight
discrimination is still discrimination
exactly and that's what race-based
preferences are and it doesn't it
doesn't help the beneficiaries i mean i
got on an airplane
yesterday and the pilot was a female
i don't want to know that uh the
airlines had some sort of gender equity
program and therefore that's why she's
i don't want to hear about it i want to
make sure she aced the flight exam
seriously we've got uh uh a big a big
story to talk about for the members
section where it's gonna get
substantially more um
let's just say less more politically
incorrect but fun and important
conversation that's gonna be at
timcast.com
i wanna stress that because there there
are many points to be made on
how the democrats are handling the
issues of race in this country and
it's funny how they always the the right
will call them the real racists then
they say oh they're going to call those
the real racists and i'm like bro you're
literally trying to implement race-based
policies to restrict people based on
race and i'm not talking about white
people like if people complain that
someone who's white is being held back
because of their race i'm like that's
legitimate but you're also going after
latinos and asians as well like you're
just creating these weird
race-based policies that are just bad
for everybody
absolutely when i moved to cleveland in
1977 i'm from l.a lakers
rams dodgers were all winners
and the cavaliers sucked
i was born so a guy named ted stephen
advertising guy very wealthy said that
he was going to buy the cavaliers and
when they bought the cavaliers he said
i'm going to put more white players on
the court because at the time the
coliseum was in an area called richfield
which was way outside of cleveland a
largely white area and he felt the white
fans would would would attend games more
if the starting five were more likely to
be white oh no he bought the team
jamie and he did just that
four of the five starters were white
okay the team lost more games
than the year the year before they drew
fewer fans in the year before they found
out white people didn't like watching
white people to lose anymore they want
to watch black people lose and the nba
took the team away from him and
implemented a rule called the step in
rule which is still in effect today
which means you cannot trade
back-to-back first-round picks the way
he did to get these white players you
ever heard of scottie wedman no mike
bratz no they were two of the starters
for the cleveland cavaliers did he bring
in mark price during that time or was
that after that was after well after but
he didn't know him then
all right everybody if you haven't
already i can't believe you brought him
up i'm from ohio i know
this morning i'm talking to somebody
from georgia tech having breakfast with
him and i said there was a player that
went to georgia tech around the time of
you there his first name was mark he was
a great point guard he was an all-time
nba free throw percentage shooter and i
couldn't think of his last name and you
just now gave it to him
yeah all right
what are the odds of me talking about
marx and you've hanging mark
we are
maybe there's a god but anyway
head over to timcast.com head over to
tim cast his last name
all right smash that like button head
over to timcast.com we're gonna have
another segment coming up the uncensored
much more
incorrect not family-friendly version of
the show that'll be at timcast.com post
at about 11 p.m you can follow the show
at tim cast irl you can follow me at tim
cast larry do you want to shout anything
out
just follow me on twitter follow me on
truth social follow me on instagram
follow me on facebook uh my documentary
again uncle tom uh comes out on august
22nd uncle tom two uncle tom one uh is
now for free on uncle tom.com
my books are the one i'm recommending
the dear father dear son that's the
hardback and a lot like me is the
paperback
um
that's about it follow watch my
television show on epictv.com epictv.com
h we post stuff every day right on i'm
going to follow you brother right after
the show um guys you can love bomb me on
twitter at jamiekilstein uh again shout
out to everyone who followed me on
instagram because you guys know i want
to get off toxic twitter so bad but i
have so many more followers there you
can follow me on instagram at the jamie
killstein and that's where i'll be
announcing my stand-up dates on
instagram i talk a lot about um mental
health stuff twitter's more political
but yeah just follow me on social media
i love this community uh with all my
heart ian before you say anything um one
more thing elderforamerica.com it's my
political action committee raising money
to take back the house the senate to
campaign against critical race theory in
favor of school choice and for
initiatives to strengthen families
elderforamerica.com throw a little
something in the tip jar thank you mr
elder dr killstein
ladies and gentlemen
we're on the precipice of an evolution
towards a new
world order of sorts and it's up to us
to decide how this evolution occurs if
you will be a passive standard by
watching it happen
or if you will participate in the
creation of the future now is the time
for you to decide and take action i'll
see you there
all true and correct thank you guys very
much thank you larry so much for coming
larry is cheering ian's last spot i love
it very much um thank you guys for
welcoming me back with such open arms
it's been a lot of fun switching with my
wrong hand um you guys can follow me on
twitter mines.com at sarah patch lids as
well as sourpatchwoods.me
we will see you all over at timcast.com
thanks for hanging out bye guys
you